September ninth.
There we go.
Got It.
Completed my homework.
Boom.
So what was the day that we were
supposed to die from Nibiru?
I think it was the 20.
It was Saturday.
Yeah,
23rd.
Is that right?
Twenty third was the champion.
Thirty three days after the eclipse.
Oh,
the Navarro was going to come and smash
us.
Wouldn't.
Isn't a huge what we see coming pretty
big.
It has to be pretty vague.
Yes.
We're pretty big.
Do you know the whole Zechariah
switching thing?
Do you know the whole thing a little
bit.
Yeah.
I was Kinda into that for awhile to
those as a while ago that I realized I
was like super into it.
Like art bell days just don't love our
birthdays.
I remember when his son got kidnapped.
Oh,
that's really weird.
I don't know real.
I couldn't tell if it was real or not.
That's the problem.
Yeah.
I used to listen to it.
Coming home from the comedy store.
That was the thing to listen to clock
late night driving home.
Totally.
Art Bell night.
Art Bell live from pahrump.
Nevada had like this fenced in compound
and prompt Nevada with a radio signal.
I mean he is like in a lot of ways.
He was like,
do an internet before the Internet get.
Yeah,
you're right.
He was kind of like a,
like a,
like an aggregator,
like a curator means a curator is
conscious curation.
But uh,
but it,
it,
is that what you mean?
Like the content of what he was talking
about,
it was also like the,
there's a lot I've,
I would say there's a lot more people
that have access to like Ufo conspiracy
theory type stuff now because of the
Internet.
Before then our bell was like your only
source for.
Got You.
Right,
right,
right.
The.
Yeah.
The deep,
the deep cuts,
that kind of stuff.
What is this?
His son kidnapping this pretty dark sun.
Assaulted by HIV teacher.
Oh Jesus.
Let's not put that on fucking.
There's people out there.
Yeah,
I know.
But art bell had this a crazy fenced in
compound that literally looked like it
was in the middle of this open prairie
was pictures of it.
Yeah.
They put pictures online might.
Who knows what I was looking at,
might not even been that.
It might have been like fake people out
with this.
He brought my live in a regular house.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You want him to live in that situation.
I hope he's,
he's kind of like a,
you know,
in a way he was like a mystic.
Those types of people,
they're kind of like mistakes.
They hermits,
they live in these weird places because
they have to be,
you know,
in the right conditions to receive the
information.
Yeah.
There's his house.
See it's all fenced in.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
that's a very large.
That's a weird.
Well,
that's what we're going over the.
He's got windmills for electricity.
Wow.
He's got some big SORTA truck.
He's got backed in there and we get
probably supplies.
He was a total prepper.
That's amazing.
That's incredible.
That's.
And it's blue blueish teal or something.
So like a Beverly Hills rundown motel
color,
like,
you know,
it was a rambler off tans and off blues.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Look at that tower,
the radio tower tower in the middle of
his yard.
That can't give you cancer candidate.
No.
Should be right now.
If something's going on it never.
They would never do anything.
I don't know.
That's A.
Oh,
I know what that is.
That's a thing.
That's a TV.
Aerial radio.
Maybe it's radio,
but it looks like an old school tv
thing.
It's fucking huge towers he has now
because he must.
Yeah,
because he used.
He probably.
He did.
He broadcast from there,
so yeah.
In a way as another internet reference,
art bell was the first time I heard a
terence McKenna outside of a building
takes joke.
One Bill Hicks joke.
Oh,
he said Kenneth,
he was talking about five grams of dried
mushrooms or with Terence Mckenna would
refer to as a heroic dose.
Yes,
and I was like,
wow.
Who's terence?
Mckenna?
And I heard transfer can out in the art
bell show live what?
Hawaii.
Terence Mckenna had this crazy setup in
Hawaii where he lived in Kona on the
mountain and he was totally off the
grid,
but way more than art bell.
He was in the jungle off the grid.
He would have these basins to catch
rainwater.
He had several acres around him which
was growing psychedelic plants.
He had a thousand books.
He lived totally by himself.
He had like a generator for power and he
was completely off the grid and he built
the house there,
dude heavy.
It was just up there writing and
tripping and then he would leave like
every six months he would take off and
leave for six months and just do these
tours where you would do these speaking
things in like hippie places like
Austin,
Texas and Portland,
Oregon and shit like that.
And they would gather around all these
people to listen to all this stuff and
if you ever heard psychedelic salon,
psychedelics salons,
a podcast,
a great podcast and I just have.
I've had Lorenzo from psychedelic salon
on,
but it's all like old recordings of
Timothy leary and Alan Watts are you
related and I really wished that I was
related to him.
That would be rather nice,
profound and with an English accent,
but he has all the mckenna recordings,
like all of them,
like way back,
way back through time.
He plays them all the time.
Mckenna was W,
which time period as sometimes get
confused with leary.
He was posts Leery,
but he was there.
He was there during that era,
but he came into prominence post leary.
Um,
I think his main psychedelic experiences
were in the seventies.
I'm like,
he had some really,
really crazy mushroom trips with his
brother Dennis,
who's an amazing guy.
Dennis is alive.
He's alive.
He's been on this podcast several times.
He's a great guy.
He's amazing.
And he's actually a professor.
And Dennis,
I'm
like recounts all these tales.
And one time terence and Dennis went
into the jungle and they took too many
mushrooms and Dennis completely lost his
mind.
He went away for two weeks,
for two weeks,
just incoherent rambling.
Had some sort of a psychotic event and
just like broke down.
The nature of reality itself just went
way too deep.
It was gone for like two weeks.
They had to watch him to watch over him.
Oh my God.
It's almost like he was exposed to such
a complicated mathematical equation and
it took him that long to figure it out
and it came out of it.
It's like,
okay,
I figured it out.
I'm back,
but you know,
terrance came up with the idea of the
stoned ape theory and it wasn't just
tenant terrence.
It was terrence along with a lot of
other psychedelic researchers.
They sort of formulated some of the
parts of this hypothesis,
but the parts of this hypothesis had to
deal with human beings evolving from
lower primates because the lower
primates,
we're forced to try out new foods
because the rain forest were receding in
the grasslands and all these undulate
too.
We're eating up all the plants as
they're growing up.
They were shitting and they were leaving
cow patties and in these cow patties,
the mushrooms,
of course we grow,
so these monkey people like things were
us that we're living in the trees.
They were forced to test out new food
sources and it coincides.
It's theory coincides with climate data
that we know about changing of the
temperatures back in Africa during that
time.
Yeah,
and in these particular regions and he
thinks that these lower primates started
experimenting with mushrooms.
It started eating,
you know,
the flip cow patties all the time to get
beetles and bugs and things along those
lines and so they will and they would
pick these mushrooms out to see if they
could eat them well in low doses.
Mushrooms enhanced visual acuity,
so it would help you be a better hunter,
makes you more sensitive and it makes
you more horny,
which would make you more likely to
breed,
so you'd be more likely to be a
successful hunter and more likely to
breed.
That's,
that's,
that's like,
that's like a triple threat,
right?
Crazy.
And that's outside of the psychedelic
effects,
right?
The psychedelic effects of enhancing
community of creative thinking.
All these things that happen when you do
mushrooms in varying doses and he
believes that mushrooms are responsible
for the doubling of the human brain size
over a period of 2 million years,
which is apparently the biggest mystery
in the fossil record.
They have no idea.
It's so quick,
so it's a total departure and it's the
organ responsible for the fossil record
in the first place.
Right,
exactly.
Understanding of what the fossil record
and the reason why we're writing all
this stuff down.
I mean it's because of the mind.
Will this mind doubled over a period of
2 million years and I think they,
what they think is there's a bunch of
different factors.
It's no,
people argue about this,
but I think it's really important to be
balanced about this and go.
I don't know if it's either or.
I think there was a bunch of shit going
on.
Yeah,
absolutely.
If they think it had to do with humans
figuring out
fire and how to cook meat,
they think cooking me allowed people to
get more nutrients which allowed people
to be healthier.
Um,
and if you can kill one animal,
you'd have more resources to sort of
figure things out and start thinking of
shelters and weapons and all these
different,
various things that lead to
civilization.
There's one theory that goes in that
way,
that trade,
the throwing arm is another one.
The fact that we could throw,
that,
we could throw things,
we could hit shit.
There was nowhere near us like no other
animal and then once we figured out
spears,
we started like this,
this ability to do this one thing might
have led us to enough free time to start
innovating.
Then the brain as time went on favored
the ones who are more innovative and
more more disciplined and more creative
and those are the ones that survive
longer,
which is obviously what we're rewarding
people today.
No,
that's true.
Fascinate hasn't gone away now.
That doesn't go away at that totally
makes sense.
I mean it's like,
you know,
if you in general the idea of awareness
and consciousness as a,
as a metaphor,
it's many people use it,
but just like a computer operating
system.
So,
so,
or you know,
consciousness experiencing itself
infinitely,
you know,
but like that's like this form of an
operating system and the,
the.
We live in a binary of version of a
isolate which,
which is kind of like a game,
you know,
to them rediscover the,
the,
the fact that that's not true.
It is true.
But it's also not true,
you know,
to arrive at the paradox to that,
the answer of the thing that happens
within a paradox,
you know,
like a good joke.
Right?
Right.
When you're,
when you're like,
here's the setup,
here's the punchline.
And so if somewhere when those two
things collide in a group of people,
it will trigger a reaction and if it's
laugh,
laughter in that moment,
it's,
it's understanding of paradox.
It's like feeling the effects of a
paradox where it actually like a very
unique moment of crazy thing that like
you didn't expect to experience because
it's so different than everything else
you experienced in everyday life.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like everything and nothing
simultaneously.
Like you get that quick because a joe
kind of does that at least in my
opinion.
And,
and,
and that makes you feel like it gives
everyone a sense of enlightenment for,
for a moment.
I know what you're saying.
I don't think a joke does it the way a
psychedelic experience that
indefinitely.
There's like this weird moment when
you're laughing at someone who's really
killing.
Like when you,
you,
you escape from your,
the shackles of your normal thinking.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
totally.
And you and you,
it's just a joyfulness because it's a,
it's like you get this perspective.
It's like such a zoomed out perspective
on this thing in such a small incident
of time that it just said it's like
being on a ride,
you know,
it's like you're just suddenly there and
you know.
Do you feel like when I've been talking
about this a lot,
do you feel like that what's going on is
like a form of hypnosis when a comedian
is like killing over a crowd.
Like it's like a form of hypnosis
because I always feel like when I'm
watching someone on stage and they
really got me,
I'm not really thinking I'm,
we'll kind of allowing them to think for
me and I'm just like sitting down,
smiling and enjoying the ride.
They take me out.
I'm not doing any analyzing myself.
Especially that's like one of the
reasons why it's very important to like
really think carefully about people's
attention spans and how to get these
ideas into their head.
I think it is in a way,
it's like a state of mind that you
achieve on stage that's very similar to
hypnosis.
Yeah.
You're talking about the effect on
people or on Youtube and the idea of
what's happened.
I think the comedian as well because I
feel like it's my job to put all the
pieces together and practice it and just
tweak it and to.
But when I get on stage and it starts
happening,
I feel like I'm as much of a passenger
as I am the driver.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
That's a really great description.
Yeah,
I agree with that 100 percent.
I mean,
you know,
like sometimes I'll say that the feeling
that I get on stage if I'm,
you know,
making music or even just like riffing
or whatever is that I feel like I'm
actually,
I'm,
I'm watching the show or I'm actually
stepped out of myself and I'm actually
kind of enjoying the show.
There'll be a moment where I'll be like,
oh fuck right.
I'm,
I'm also doing now snap back in.
But in those moments,
that's I.
that's exactly.
I dig.
I dig that because it exists.
It's just depends on where your
awareness lands.
You know what?
I always feel like,
man,
I always feel like the dude running the
old school movie projector because
you're really just kind of turn it on,
but you have to be there in case
anything fucks up.
Yeah.
For the most part it runs on its own.
Do you remember the movies?
Yeah,
there was a uh,
yeah,
there was an operator.
There is a.
yeah,
there was just someone next to it just
in case something fucked up.
Do you remember when movies fucked up
and you don't have to yell out.
Oh yeah,
I do remember that.
Yeah,
those are great.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
The fuck ups,
the chaos.
That's the community.
That's a real test of character to see
whether you're talking to a movie
theater.
Oh yeah.
What do you mean?
Like the kind of people that talk and
movie player during a movie,
like you really know whether or not you
can hang out with someone if they talk
in a movie.
Yes,
absolutely.
One hundred percent.
Because if someone starts talking to the
movie theater,
you're like,
hey,
you're inconsiderate.
Yeah.
Oh totally.
Or unless like,
you know,
for me,
I have this little secret that once,
if,
if it's,
uh,
a brief comment,
I don't really mind so much,
but yeah,
the secret get really quiet and get
close to their ear and don't whisper,
just speaking kind of a like,
Hey,
what am I?
Right?
Because the higher your whisper is,
it's much more siblings and everyone can
hear it.
So whispers are actually allowed to put
a hushed tone anyway.
Also the people that just start talking
about normal shit.
Oh yeah,
totally has nothing to do with the
movie.
It'd be called Maki now you asshole.
Sky's going to get killed by a robot
lady.
She interested in seeing how that even
comes to being shut the fuck up.
She's about to kill A.
Troy was really angry the other day
talking about troy where were at the
movie Avatar to motherfucker.
It's,
Gosh,
it's in three.
I'm wearing glasses.
That's the crazy thing.
Hey,
you know,
it's just coming out this fall.
I don't really watch.
It.
Gives a fuck what's going to happen in
the future.
You might not even be alive.
I might kill you for talking to the
movie theater,
so either you have no idea how I'm going
to react.
Really taking a big risk.
Man,
I'm really hungry.
Let's get something to eat after this,
but fighter people that can't even wait
an hour to eat like,
no,
I have to be filled.
I need to fill my holes because the
holes get lonely.
I need to fail my face hole with food
immediate.
I can't survive.
That's tough,
man.
That's a tough racket because some
people,
I dunno some.
I mean obviously there are people that
have like this weird thing that happens
when you know that hangry thing or
whatever.
Bloodshot u,
so then they,
they kind of get crazy.
However,
I will say for the most part it's about
discipline and the discipline turns into
just nature and then you get a better
sense of how if you are hungry,
you're like,
you know what?
I'm hungry and that's fine.
Yeah,
you can be fine.
I'm going to.
I'm going to be hungry.
I can live for a few days without days,
so.
So a few hours or four hours extra.
I'm going to be fine.
Did you hear about the guy that lost
like more than 100 pounds by fasting for
an entire year?
He had a doctor's monitoring him.
It was all part of some sort of
scientific experiment and we had to.
We were talking about him with Robb
Wolf.
Correct.
Is that who was telling us about it or
was it dom d'agostino?
Not like in the sixties or something?
No,
no,
no.
It was fairly recently,
fairly recently because the doctors were
monitoring him.
He lost over 100 pounds and here's
what's really crazy.
His skin shrunk with him,
like his body corrected for itself,
which is like what?
Because he went into a complete state of
Ketosis,
right where his body is only fuel was
from the actual extra fat in his bio and
then when his body started consuming
this mean he could have like really
bizarre genetics where skin doesn't
stretch out.
Is this,
this is it,
right?
Four hundred 50 pound man faster for a
year and he lost more than half his
weight.
Yeah,
I think that's it.
It happened in 1965.
Was that the same one?
See if there's a recent photo,
because if rob lowe was talking about
that they had all these color photos of
the guy that looked really recent,
you might be right,
but I think.
I think it was a recent.
Maybe they recreated it.
Maybe that's what it was,
but this guy,
whatever it was,
all he did.
Oh,
is this the same one?
Same One.
I'm all
he did was drink water and his body just
ate it's fat.
I don't know if it took vitamins or
what.
He had to take some for some fiber
because they need stuff to go through,
so I wish Rob Wolf was here.
I'm pretty sure he's the one who told us
about it.
What I think was was the most shocking
was that a skin trump.
That's,
that's the.
That's the.
That's the weird thing.
I mean,
I mean with weight loss,
I lost like 50,
55 pounds.
Damn,
I should do that.
I just started lifting.
I got a trainer and started lifting and
then basically eating like a
bodybuilder,
so just.
And that's how I eat.
For the most part,
they feel better that way.
Oh Man.
Way Better.
It's crazy like crazy food.
Like people sometimes will look at the
food that I'm bringing,
which is always pretty much the same
thing.
I'm like,
what are you eating?
Like you know,
like for breakfast it's like this what I
call the year or what he calls the Yogi
shake.
My trainer,
he has this shake that he that he digs
and it's like half key for half a cup
of.
Yeah,
a cup of oats,
raw oats,
a half a cup of Keifer,
half cup of water,
and then 35 grams of a j.
rob chocolate,
egg,
white protein.
Oh.
And a handful of frozen blueberries.
Damn scene.
Got a lot of good stuff going on there.
You've got students,
you've got probiotics from the key.
You've got some carbs from the oats.
Yep.
You've got protein.
Yeah.
See we just eat good.
It's so funny because.
But the problem is there's a lot of
fucking dummies that also eat good and
they're annoying and for regular people
that want to be healthy,
but they don't want to be that annoying
guy.
The gym that's just fucking,
just droning on and on about his sets in
his lifts and you start thinking that
being healthy is for idiots.
Yes.
Right.
I know it gives it a bad rap.
It tells me that it's,
it's not,
it's not that,
you know,
my,
my favorite thing that I've been
learning,
like lifting and sometimes they go to
Gold's on Saturday,
like as a treat.
So like we go to Gold's in Venice and
it's what I love about anything that I
get involved with is just observing like
how the system works,
you know,
and like yeah,
the community,
like what's the level of awareness,
like what are they focused on,
those types of things.
And the thing I really dig about lifting
is that it's not what you think.
Like I think people think like,
oh meatheads no roided up,
blah blah blah blah blah.
And don't get me wrong.
There are some of those for sure.
And um,
it wouldn't be a real gym without,
without a couple,
but like you go into,
you go into gold and man,
people are so respectful,
very friendly,
very respectful.
They help me like rack rack their
weights,
they help you,
they rerock if you're working in,
um,
they uh,
get things out of the way they think
about like,
stuff like being in the way or not.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of like really cool
conscious,
hey,
let me help you.
Oh,
you know,
that lift that you're doing with those
putting too much stress on your,
on your shoulder,
you might want to like,
pull in a little bit with your elbow or
whatever.
Just a tip.
You know,
those guys are great guys that are
annoying.
Or the guys that want to correct you in
the wrong man.
No,
don't do that.
You got to exercise.
You know,
what would I do that,
you just can't do it.
There's guys that just have this idea in
their head that they need to absolutely
tell you their knowledge.
Oh man,
it must come out now.
It's,
it's weird.
Any can tell the difference because like
if someone's like giving you a small
piece of corrective advice for an
exercise that you're doing in the moment
or that you're doing.
So it's not a critique of the exercises,
so it's more like I'm looking at you
doing this exercise and here's a little
piece that might make it more efficient,
better,
better use of your movement or whatever
you.
That's great.
I get that.
And you can get that right away.
Like,
oh,
that's dope.
I'll try that.
And if it works,
it works.
If it doesn't,
it doesn't,
you know,
but when someone's like going off on
these giant concepts like these,
uh,
just,
just things that are too large to give
to someone that you don't know and they
just start firing it out at you.
Yeah.
All these physiological words.
You know what?
I don't even know what you're saying.
Know what the word I'm not.
I don't want to look stupid.
I.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Totally.
Well,
yeah,
I mean if we can.
Yeah,
sure man.
Thanks man.
Thank you.
All that isolated my scapula reporting,
but my superspinatus and all these words
like,
oh,
what are you doing here?
Do you feel like you're jerking off on
me or tricking off on me with your
knowledge,
knowledge jerking.
There is knowledge jerking right?
Pretty sure that they definitely
knowledge.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
and it gets grouped in with
mansplaining,
which I think is like another form of.
It's too generalized general human term.
Have you heard he pete?
It's a new one.
Oh,
it's that he peed is when a woman says
something and everybody ignores it and
the man says the exact same thing.
Oh,
great idea.
Fucked.
I know that.
I know what that is and that's fucked.
I did not like that.
There's nothing that pisses me off.
Morris here loving.
Let me capitalize on an idea that was
not really delivered in the right timing
or whatever.
It's like,
but I'm just going to claim
responsibility.
Don't say debbie just had a great idea.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's the difference between a good
person.
A county person.
Man.
Debbie just had a good idea as a good
person.
Hey everybody who had a great idea.
The bad guys like.
Yeah,
totally.
And Debbie's like,
what?
Thought?
Debbie doesn't know what to do.
This fucking job sucked yet totally
this.
I knew this guy was an asshole.
Here's my proof.
That culture of like not like being in a
corporate world and like one person is
the boss and the other people who have
to kiss his ass on the boss,
but then the boss has a boss,
the regional boss was coming by,
everybody tighten up and he's got to put
a tie on.
Know I know the only time that system
works is if the boss is a really good
person and being a boss,
that's the only time which is very,
very rare.
It's super rare because they're playing
against it.
That's what's happening.
Well,
you have to exist.
You have to exist by while ignoring
all the trappings of bosses.
Yeah.
Right,
right,
right.
If you're just looking at like just from
a rational logistic like efficient
making mindset like you want you want
you want and what the value of
efficiency also relates to the happiness
of the workers and their wellbeing.
Not Coddling too much,
but providing just the just the right
amount of things,
plus a little bit extra to give it the
grease that it needs to feel good.
Finding people to fill your team that
are likeminded or willing to like kind
of think that way where everybody kind
of works together almost as a family.
Yes,
exactly.
I'm sure those jobs exist.
I know I've talked to people who love
their jobs.
I know there's people like that that are
putting it together.
Right?
I think that there are companies and if
not there are moments when companies are
like that because everything changes,
so it might not be sustainable if we
keep going.
I feel like people don't.
People like to look at the worst aspects
of any point in time.
Right.
Whether it's climate change or a crazy
presidential situation or race relations
or whatever.
We always look at the worst aspects of
it,
but I think overall it's pretty
undeniable this is the best time ever to
be alive in terms of healthcare,
in terms of the science behind to
keeping people alive in terms of your
ability to get information in terms of
our ability to communicate with each
other and bullshit to get through.
To us.
It's way less likely to bullshit gets
through to people today.
Then the propaganda they could spew just
in like the 19 sixties.
Oh,
get over on us.
That's been the Gulf of Tonkin thing,
like the whole thing,
the whole reason why we got into war.
So I just think that if we can keep it
together and we can keep going.
I think 40 years from now,
50 years from now that's going to.
I think we're going to realize that that
should be the norm and that they're
really healthy communities is going to
be the norm and all these things.
This is like almost like a aberrations
that we,
when we look back in time and thinking
like people who were kings and they had
people under them and they executed
people at their own whim and that,
you know,
that only exists in a few places today.
It's like North Korea and like maybe a
couple other places.
I feel like in the future we're all
going to move towards it.
We're just,
it's just hard to see while we're in it,
we're all moving towards a better way of
living.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
I mean I think of it,
you know,
if I,
if I go back to that I'm like the
reality awareness issue or a,
the idea that,
you know,
there are multi verses and that every
choice splits off and makes another
choice to make another choice.
So in essence,
if just to,
in essence,
if anything is possible,
if,
if the amount of realities and
possibilities that exists are infinite
and,
but we're perceiving one point,
you know,
as a,
whatever consciousness has experiment or
whatever you want to call it,
but as your point of reference,
as you move and every choice that you
make,
you can actually steer yourself to the
reality that you want to live in.
So,
I mean,
I think that there's,
there's something great about seeing the
trajectory of what you just
described and moving towards that
future,
but being proactive in the way that you
can.
And,
but I think really the.
I think the thing that's really gonna
help all of that is energy.
Like if we can figure out a way to
distribute energy so that it's more
equal amongst all human beings on the
planet creating something.
You mean energy in terms of power,
actual power,
electrical power,
electrical power.
Yeah.
I would feel like there's a lot of
places in the earth that would benefit
from some super advanced form of solar
energy because if.
Yeah,
for sure.
Why even ever have power plants the why
have any of that stuff can all be
independent and we don't totally rely on
a grid either this way.
No,
no,
no.
It's distributed power is the,
is the best power,
especially if it is connected because
then you have.
It can manage itself.
I mean even if like,
you know,
artificial intelligence and things like
that or just really good programming,
it just optimizes constantly in real
time based on a sensor array when you
know,
they use really good back country solar
panels to charge batteries for cameras
and phones.
That's right.
My friend Adam was in Montana and he was
in Colorado,
Montana,
Idaho and Wyoming went on this epic back
country hunt and one of the things that
he did is he brought this solar thing to
charge his phone every day.
Do instastories from the top of the
mountain.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Amazing stuff.
But that you couldn't do that just a few
years ago.
I mean,
there wasn't the kind of solar power
that you could pack up and a little
thing and stuff into your backpack and
it's crazy.
I know.
Yeah.
I was telling,
I was checking out.
There's a company out of Australia that
makes these solar generators and they're
like 17 grand or something like that,
or maybe even.
Oh No,
the money would be more like 30 grand or
something.
Anyways,
it's this like fairly lightweight
system.
It's like a master system that has a
base and um,
and a solar array and it tracks the sun,
uh,
so moves automatically with the sun and
it accounts,
like,
it also has some other preprogrammed
weather data that's also integrated into
it either real time or stored.
And so it,
it.
But it's able to produce like a pretty
decent amount of electricity.
I don't remember the numbers,
but it was definitely way more than a
trickle charge.
Oh,
you could almost like,
you could run a refrigeration system on
it,
like a small refrigerator so you can
keep food from perishing.
Yeah.
Maybe even get some air conditioning
going or something.
Yeah.
I think with a storage battery 20 years
from now,
who knows this shit.
It's gonna be well,
I mean,
you know,
if I just got done seeing that,
uh,
the documentary,
I don't know.
I don't remember the name of it,
but it's a kind of kind of conspiracy
Ufo.
A fairly recent one.
Yeah.
That's fairly.
Steven Greer,
that guy.
Uh,
not sure it's on a,
it's on itunes.
Is featured on itunes.
Do you remember the name of it?
I can find it.
Like the unknown or some.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that seems right.
Yeah.
And acknowledged it.
There's art belly,
there's asked.
It was kind of our belly,
actually our belly,
those are tough shows for me to watch
because it makes sense,
like some of the stuff that they're
talking about.
And then that makes sense,
but my theory is that the level of
organization that they're talking about
doesn't really exist.
Like it's not that tight,
I think.
I think it's kind of messy.
I think it's,
it's the same thing,
like just look at kids on a playground
and see how they organize themselves
socially and then just expand that with
a little bit more complexity or more
complexity.
And you have these,
this idea of like the secrecy,
the structure of secrecy.
And uh,
yeah,
uh,
ancient,
like cults that have now risen,
you know,
Rosa crucial ones and a masons and the
Illuminati in those,
those types of things.
I think that those,
they can,
like that sort of thing does exist,
but it doesn't exist in the tight,
efficient,
controlled version.
I think it's,
I think it's messier than that.
I think it's people trying to influence
other people using a bunch of tactics.
But I think that you can't have control.
You can't have that much control as,
as much control as they're talking
about.
Well,
the only way that would work is if the
government was different than people.
Like if they,
if they weren't,
if it wasn't made,
if people got totally wasn't people,
they were so smart that they weren't,
then that could be possible.
But obviously that's not the case.
Donald trump is the fucking president.
So we have proof that the government is
filled with people.
That guy's a person.
So person,
no person has ever been able to pull off
that level of conspiracy for any length
of time.
And the idea that you could hide somehow
communication with aliens and the aliens
would choose the government of all
people.
Why would the aliens give a fuck who we
picked a popularity contest.
Oh,
that's the representative that gets to
speak to Zeta reticular the fuck outta
here.
They talked to whoever they want to go
and check when we visit a bee colony.
Excuse me,
stick on fucking secret contact.
Just suck some bees out with a vacuum.
When to take them to a lab to test them.
Listen,
I need you to go back to the need to go
to the king.
He imagined some fucking dudes sitting
in the White House,
you know,
uh,
at the Oval Office.
And the alien walks in.
I am the representative of the 19
forties movie.
Right.
Doesn't make,
it,
doesn't make any sense.
I bought,
I believe,
I believe in like so many things.
So many infinite things can exist and
things are possible.
However,
there are things that are just like,
it just makes sense.
You know,
it intuitively you can feel some
connection.
It real like,
you know what,
I'll leave a 10 percent margin of
possibility,
you know,
like something like that.
But the ideas where I'm like I can't,
I just can't.
I,
it could be real,
but I've seen nothing that compels me to
believe that it is.
But it could be real.
I'm not,
I'm definitely not saying there are no
aliens with the government hasn't been
contacted by aliens.
Aliens haven't visited.
Sure,
sure.
I mean why not do it?
I mean,
I,
I don't think it's impossible.
But again,
I think it's not in to the extent at
which when you compress all the data and
you like formulate a story about it,
you know,
it was really unlikely.
But yeah,
it's like,
well,
I dunno,
it seems you have,
you kind of have to do that.
Like you can't talk about that stuff.
It also seems super likely to me that in
the future we won't send biological
entities into these places that have all
these limitations as far as what we can
survive.
We'll send some sort of an artificial
intelligent.
Maybe that's what those things are.
Those gray things,
the big black eyes.
Maybe those are robots.
Oh man,
makes sense.
Within the question is,
is my theory is that the whole
propulsion or compulsion to,
to,
to constantly be making technology is
based on our desire to make or build
ourselves outside of ourselves.
Yeah.
So without the,
the normal biological means,
it's like we're fascinated at.
We're fascinated at simulating ourselves
outside of ourselves.
And so in essence,
we could just be that already.
Right?
And so,
so it's like we're just like on this
constant carrot chasing a propulsion
system.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that when they
look at the image of the alien,
they,
uh,
they look at that image and they say
that it's entirely preposterous.
It's someone who would achieve or
something would achieve a humanoid shape
with all the massive amounts of
different shapes that we have on earth.
Yes.
Just to be mobile,
that's not the only way to be mobile and
know we know how ours came to be that we
used to be crawling and then we started
standing up.
Right.
That's why we have all these issues with
our spine.
Spine wasn't entirely designed to
support upper body weight.
That's right.
Yeah,
that's right.
and you know,
the other thing is it's one of my pet
peeves and just putting this into the
spectrum of science fiction.
Every,
every celestial body,
every planet,
every moon had.
They all have different gravity's.
Yeah,
so there's going to be different types
of creatures.
Not only that,
but when they come to our planet,
there is going to need a really strong
exoskeleton suit or they're going to be
so incredibly strong that it wouldn't
matter.
Also,
atmospheric gases,
like all you know,
like how they produce energy,
other.
There's such a vast complexity that we
life is the way that it is now because
of all of the elements that were present
at the Times that they were present in
our reality.
And so,
and even if you take it on a software
level,
like something like a,
what was that game spore,
um,
where it was like,
it was built on like generative entire
university and they would and they would
kind of create on their own based on
like your light touch and it would be
infinite.
Jamie,
didn't you say that?
That got boring though,
because there's really nothing happening
in these infinite.
Oh,
that's a no,
no,
no man's sky.
Yep,
Yep.
No Man's sky.
So similar idea.
Yeah.
That's,
you have to really,
you know,
the problem with those things is,
I know we're jumping around a lot,
but I just,
that's the whole show is the show.
Okay.
We jump around and were like,
okay,
so when should we start talking about
whatever?
Yeah,
totally good.
I like it.
There's ain't no rules.
So when you,
oh,
so this is what is this?
These are creatures just came out like
probably 10,
15 years ago.
It's just dope.
It starts super small,
little one celled organisms and works
all the way up to a organism getting on
land and then you're really running a
whole planet.
So when these,
these things are happening,
these little fuckers evolve.
They evolve,
you can design,
you can design them.
That's hilarious.
And what do you,
what are your tasks?
Oh,
you have to fight and survive or
whatever.
Or you can get lost in these fucking
puddings,
man.
Then you can use.
And now there's like tribal culture with
a hierarchical leadership.
Now are these other things you're
interacting with?
Artificial or the other humans playing
games all.
Yeah.
This was multiplayer online stuff.
Yeah,
so basically you have all the way to
space fairing too.
They're so cool looking.
They beat the fuck out of each other
with sticks though.
I've got to get past that Shit,
man.
See?
See,
that's.
I know.
See that's the thing.
That's the thing about that makes us,
that's what I call human beings,
the human race simulation species.
It's like everything that we,
that we do,
we generate our ideas,
they're all based on like our
observation of the world around us and
then utilizing that in some way for our,
for ourselves and so like know design of
things,
why we color things the way they are,
certain chemicals or why things are,
you know,
look the way they look or the shape,
the way they're shaped all of that.
So when I see a game about simulation,
of course we're going to make simulation
a game about simulations,
arguably a like children playing with
dolls and figures and stuff like that.
It's another form of simulation,
but the idea of like having the
awareness of another reality and
projecting the idea that you want more
with bigger,
I guess some more control.
Yeah.
I'm having control over representation
of your idea of,
of a desired reality is crazy.
It's crazy.
I mean that's like,
that's like simulation within
simulation,
within simulation,
within.
It's,
it's totally a,
to me,
a nice piece of evidence for that.
Yeah.
I think we're going to get better at it
and it's going to get into certain
animal.
You're going to be able to put some
headphones on and they're going to plug
some stuff,
maybe put some,
some of those,
uh,
greasy pads,
some wires,
some wetware yeah.
They're going to stuff connected
to your head and all these various
places.
They're going to hook you up with this
machine and you're going to go somewhere
that's so much cooler than reality.
You're going to be like,
fuck reality,
man.
You're gonna.
You're gonna,
you're gonna.
Go and do your stupid job at home depot.
And you're like,
fuck this job.
You're gonna come home and you're going
to put that thing on.
I have to figure out a way to stay in
here.
Stay in the world like surrogate tron
world.
What surrogates recut the movie a Bruce
Willis.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
I remember that movie.
Remember that?
It was all,
it was all about telepresence.
So people were like,
just in pods,
but it's Kinda like a robot bottom.
Yeah.
And there were people like jumping off
of buildings and shit because they
could.
There were no consequences.
So they looked like underneath.
Yeah,
half.
Whoa.
Freaky surrogate robot.
Yeah.
Bruce Willis was younger.
There was like one of the first uses of
CGI to,
to make someone younger in a movie.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Like,
look how beautiful.
His skin looked.
Very smooth,
super smooth.
They just did that recently with,
um,
guardians of the galaxy two with who?
I'm Russell Kurt.
Russell is the bad guy.
Yeah.
You know,
the feet of the one time that I noticed
the most was Tron,
the neutral.
That's where they,
like,
I remember that being like,
espouses this breakthrough to.
I mean Benjamin Button,
like fake,
just fuck.
It looked fake as fuck.
I mean,
it wasn't a simulation in the fact that
it wasn't a simulation.
A video game still looks fake within the
video.
Kurt Russell,
that looked amazing.
Simple dude.
He looked perfect.
I mean,
he looked really good.
It looks.
Yeah,
no,
that looks.
It looks like a 35 year old Kurt.
Russell was fucking incredible.
It looks great.
It is really good.
And the movie's Funny Shit.
Oh,
it's,
you're talking about too.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
the one thing that really pissed me off
was that baby groot,
I hate when they put baby characters.
I don't like,
can't stand it.
It's so obvious.
It's such an obvious play.
It's just like,
it's like,
remember it is obvious when mark and
mindy,
when they add a Jonathan winters.
I didn't,
I wasn't afraid of obvious things that
are awesome,
like big tits.
They worked once.
Okay.
That's a totally different thing,
man.
It's a totally different thing,
but obvious things that are awesome.
There's a,
there's another.
I know that little baby groot was cute.
I could not stand that opening sequence
with like the,
he's like being casual and he's taken
out all the bad guys and I'm like,
that's so gross.
I thought when I was singing.
Oh yeah.
Like with the,
with the,
it's the opening sequence.
I loved it.
I mean I couldn't,
I didn't know.
You know what though?
Dude,
I'm a Dork.
Comic books man have always been a Dork
for comic books and Comic Book Movies
and I'm,
I'm so get like I'll make fun of people
for like pro,
like,
you know,
it's fake.
You know,
it's like,
I know it's fake.
That's not the point.
Yeah,
it was.
Game of thrones is fake.
Tim will go back and forth.
Meanwhile,
I'll get fucking thrilled when David
Bruce Banner turns into the hulk.
Oh,
I love that shit.
Yeah.
I get amped up.
Oh,
I love that.
That,
that I have no problem with.
That's so corny though.
I liked.
No,
that's not going to make me angry.
I didn't like me when I'm angry.
I love that shit.
I always do that.
Have you ever heard that?
Uh Oh.
Can you imagine what's,
what's his name?
A British comedian.
I'm really brilliant.
Kind of all guy did a jerry springer the
musical and it didn't take.
It didn't take off.
And then all these questions like
protesting,
um,
there are protests.
These music.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
It was like,
it was like really big and it didn't
happen or something like that.
Like the theater,
like decided not to do it or something
like that.
Oh,
that's fine.
I'm rich.
It's so crazy.
What is it?
Richard Thomas?
No,
no,
not Richard Thomas.
It's,
um,
he's got a,
he's got a program right now is on TV,
BBC,
but anyways,
he's this,
he's this brilliant.
Um,
he has a joke about Ang Lee guy did the
hawk.
Yeah.
So yeah,
so his whole thing is just insane.
It's a long joke.
It takes like seven minutes.
The setup,
it's just him talking about how he was,
he worked with Angley and at the end of
this interview he said,
Ang Lee,
you wouldn't like me when I'm Lee.
Something actually not getting it.
And then him explaining the whole lead
up back to that again and then not
getting it and explaining it again and
it just goes,
it's,
I think I'm remembering it right.
But it's just brilliant man.
It's such an abstract,
weird slice of a way to get to a
punchline and it's just,
it's perfect.
A Hog,
a punchline that's a hulk of arguably
the worst hulk movie.
Yeah,
definitely.
Definitely.
The West Eric Bana one who's,
I loved him in chopper,
but it didn't love them as Bruce Banner.
Yeah.
Even though it was last name was banner
and I thought that's pretty close to
banner.
It didn't do it.
You know why terrible Bonnie on that
movie.
I went to see it high.
And when you see high movies,
bad movies just like or offensive when
you're high.
Like what?
What do you make believe?
But I know I'm aware of the illusion.
You're casting wizard.
Yeah,
that's a problem.
Maybe they had hot dogs in that one.
Yeah,
I didn't service it was like three,
three or two headed dogs.
Was that two headed?
I remember it was a dog.
Yes.
I think it had more than one head.
I think because it was.
It was nick nolte,
his dogs.
He was the dad.
Remember he was a scientist.
Dad?
Yeah,
that's right.
They turn into a jellyfish
set.
That one returning to jellyfish.
At the end he had jellyfish dogs.
Look at them.
Oh yeah.
No,
they weren't holding down poodle in the
hotel pistol.
Weird.
What a weird look at them.
That's amazing.
What a strange thing going to be facing
down poodle.
I mean.
Yeah,
that's.
I remember that happened.
It essentially turned into the hulk
versus a hog dog,
so when the dogs would get fired up,
the same thing would happen to them as
happened to the right.
Yeah,
that's right.
Hulk dogs get bigger.
Look at that thing.
Bite them on the back and didn't he get
bigger depending upon how much fucked up
shit was happening in his life.
Like he shot him with bullets.
He kept getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger.
Yeah,
maybe.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Yeah,
I remember that.
because he just keeps absorbing the
energy.
Yeah.
So like in the nuclear plant matter,
it just kept getting bigger.
That's right.
Could you fucking imagine like of all
the superpowers,
that's the one that I think so appeals
to kids like me when I was young,
I was little and worried about the world
and nervous and you know,
you get picked on you like how cool
would it be to just be able to just get
angry and all of a sudden become this
bulletproof thing that can leak through
the air.
That's the most.
It's like freedom.
Yeah.
Freedom.
But it was so corny,
like the words that he would say that
they.
You could only read it.
Oh yeah.
It as a comic book,
when you're reading a comic book,
it's different than when you hear people
speaking like the avengers when he takes
a.
What is it?
Loci loci pizza.
The fuck out of him.
He knew human.
Oh yeah.
No,
no,
no.
But if you saw the 19 seventies hulk,
Lou ferrigno just like,
I mean comic,
like just like,
like he's beating the fuck out of Blokey
bloke.
He's kind of like,
like kind of fucked up and all.
Because just being emotionless and said
that you'd be like,
yeah,
that makes sense.
He would say that he would definitely
say that.
And that's cool.
Yeah.
There's a lot of things that you could
only read people saying.
Yeah,
totally.
Like Annie Cap.
I mean,
no one says,
yeah,
Andy Capp.
Wow.
That's a blast from the past.
Titch.
Is there any more cartoons?
Are there any more dilbert's out there
in the world?
Do you mean like hand drawn comic
strips?
They're big ones that people like look
forward to everyday.
There must be.
You're about to hear from some.
From.
Sure.
Right.
Get ready to read the newspaper
probably.
Right,
right.
But who the fuck reads newspapers
anymore?
I don't know man.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and online publications,
unless it's The new yorker,
you usually don't do,
um,
comic strips.
It's just the articles and if they do,
it's probably like a one off by an
artist rather than a series like Andy
Capp or Dilbert or,
you know what I mean?
Totally.
It's maybe a one off with Obama and
trump standing next to each other
talking or something like that.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
It's just a picture.
It's like playboy style picture.
The punchline.
Joke underneath.
Yeah.
I remember those playboy ones where
you're like,
whoa,
this is crazy.
I was a little kid.
Get Ahold of them and be like,
what in the fuck am I reading right now?
General,
their tits popping out and the guys
trying to grab her and it's humor.
Adult humor.
It's adult humor,
but today it's totally rape culture,
like a lot of shit that was in playboy
magazine and those,
those ads that if you saw or those
cartoons rather than as you saw today,
you'd be like,
you can't print this because there's no
fucking way.
No way is a.
I mean it's.
Is it as bad?
No,
it is.
It is.
I was just gonna say this is as bad as
Mickey Rooney in breakfast at Tiffany's.
I don't remember that movie.
Yeah,
that don't.
I mean watch it,
but as soon as Mickey Rooney's character
comes on,
I've ever seen that.
Which doesn't really know.
It makes sense.
Breakfast at tiffany's is like one of
those movies you,
you hear about all the time,
but you may not ever see it.
Yeah.
That might be the case.
I might not have ever seen it.
I remember trying to see it and I
couldn't.
I couldn't finish it because of Mickey
Rooney.
He plays a Chinese man.
Oh God.
That's running Japanese.
Japanese is Japanese stores.
You wearing a Japanese thing saying he's
Chinese says Mr.
Jeff [inaudible] Japanese.
Yeah.
Okay.
So at least I thought I was going to get
really terrible with like mixing Asian
cultures,
but apparently you remember when Katie
Perry had apologized for wearing a
kimono because,
uh,
people felt like it was offensive
Japanese people that she was culturally
appropriating.
She was like,
had this big sit down with a,
I don't know about her.
One of her album covers.
That was a different time when it was
acceptable.
Oh,
you're right.
You're right.
No,
no.
Last grandmother died.
So,
uh,
she,
she had apologized and she,
when she was apologizing,
remember she made this video that will
make your fucking brain hurt.
She's sitting there with a dream.
How do you say,
Maxon from black lives matter and
they're sitting on a couch,
cross legged with their shoes off.
Which by the way,
nobody knows.
Nobody knows.
It's you sit down that like that with
me.
I'm like,
Hey,
what are we doing here?
I said,
that's trying to be comfortable with it
looks weird,
terrible setup.
How about we just give us a comfy chair.
I sit here and talk to each other like
fucking humans.
It would be different if they were on
like kind of organic looking furniture
and they were dressed more as like human
people.
Um,
and I don't know,
you know what I mean?
Well,
she was addressing other hair.
This was the thing,
she had a dress her hair because she did
something where she had braids and
people were getting mad at her because
she culturally appropriate it.
And then she also addressed her,
her idea of dressing like a
geisha.
So the problem is when they went over
and talked to people,
Geishas are from,
we're geishas from.
Why don't want to say China,
Japan,
Japan is Japan,
right.
It's like the thing that people just
don't understand.
So they went over there,
there's the braids and she had
apologized for,
that's her Katy Perry.
Damn.
She looked good.
She's no good deal.
Um,
so they went over to Japan to talk to
these folks and they universally,
we're saying when the interviewed people
in the street that they're happy that
someone is expressing Japanese culture
and that they're aware of Japanese
culture.
And they thought it was a very good
thing.
They didn't think it was interesting,
like they don't have the same feelings
about cultural appropriation as some
people do with fucking braids.
Yeah.
I get it.
Well,
but it's the United States,
right?
We're sending it over super sensitive.
We've gotten very expensive.
You know what it is?
It all comes from a litigious culture
that's.
Oh,
absolutely.
The fact that you can get sued for
anything.
Anybody can sue you at anytime.
That's just like,
that's American culture.
That's what you do.
It's like,
you know what,
you pissed off someone like enough you
can sue them,
and so there's a lot of like swimming,
swimming,
swimming and enough successful cases
along the way.
That's part of,
it's like a fear based operating system,
calling people on Shit.
Yeah.
Maybe they didn't even think was bad
yet.
It's a combination of like someone like
it's a good service to be able to sue
someone if you need it to.
However it's abused of the hanging and
there's professional lawyers.
They have billboards everywhere.
But do you think Katy Perry was worried
about being sued?
No,
I'm saying that I'm saying that the
sensitivity is like why?
Why we're so,
what American culture is so pc at this
point,
because there's a,
it kind of goes hand in hand.
It's like a sense of,
well,
I don't know,
I'm,
I'm at a loss and a little bit to stand,
but,
but I will say it's it having that
litigious fear based kind of motivator
or it causes people to want to correct
things like to course correct,
to,
uh,
to a form of something that works for
everyone to avoid being sued too.
I mean,
not directly,
but that thought process.
Yeah,
that mindset.
I think that's because it's about like,
okay,
well how can we make this,
we have to include everybody on this,
which I believe in,
but absolutely.
But,
uh,
but I think it should be done out of a
sense of empathy,
you know,
and not to say that,
that,
you know,
people fighting for rights to have
handicap parking in the front of the
building.
Like that's,
that's just a great idea.
But like I'm just saying that,
that what we were kind of referring to,
that sensitivity come,
comes from that where someone's like
afraid of doing something wrong and it
just starts feeding back and feeding
back,
feeding back,
and then you get people so fearful of
any choice that they're making.
Because I feel it,
you know,
every time I walk into a grocery store,
I'm like,
this entire store
could be reduced to five percent the
volume that it,
that it is right now,
and the amount of people in that store
would have all the products they need.
Hm.
So the inundation of choice,
choice,
choice and fear of doing something
wrong.
Whether it's because I love to look
perfect or I want to look perfect,
or whatever it is.
That all mix that all together and it's
a recipe for.
I think it's a fabulous for sure.
I think another factor though is that
people get to complain and that people
don't like when people are mad at them.
So when you have a giant group of people
that can communicate instantaneously
with,
with anybody at any time,
you're going to get more prevalence of
complaining.
It's the same percentage of people are
complaining,
but they weren't able to access everyone
as they were to get to Katy Perry and
bitch about her wearing braids.
Right.
So in the past,
like in the low derek days and bowed,
Derek wore braids and 10,
which is really for that was that was
nobody was wearing those,
seen that,
not on that level.
I mean was that a thing in black culture
back then and the Bo Derek days?
What do you mean?
Like braids?
Cornrows thinks since I think the slave
days.
Some days.
Yeah.
But brands have also been in almost
every culture braids for sure.
But those crazy cornrows like that,
those that,
that was that.
Yeah,
that was a direct reference I think to
like Lord,
she was Caribbean spooky hot.
She ruined your life.
She was next door.
She was,
yeah.
She wouldn't get anything done if you
were banging her very interesting
[inaudible] you would have to like keep
an eye on.
Are All the time were you going to stay
put?
I mean,
but at the same time if you learn to be
completely confident next to someone
like that,
I mean come on.
That's like Max good fucking luck when I
can't pull it off.
You couldn't hold it all the time.
I,
I would,
I would have no problem.
You'd have to not want to fuck her.
You'd have to like be married and happy
and successful and not want to fuck her
and just like really just be comfortable
being around her.
Do you think just because you want to
have sex on that possibility,
the possibility to fuck someone that's
that hot is always a problem for men.
Especially back then.
Yeah,
it.
Yeah.
I mean I think the initial making a move
and all that stuff,
but I think like obviously if you get
used to someone and their personality,
like the,
it starts to calibrate,
you know?
It's just a better person,
a better person to go around her.
She couldn't,
she could,
if she were great it,
she,
she could.
If she had a great attitude,
she was a positive person.
You just want her to like you more or
maybe not.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
I Dunno,
I've made,
I've,
I've just said like,
I know what you're saying,
but I'm like,
at the same time,
I take that as a personal challenge and
be like,
okay,
fine.
How can I be confident around her?
I set it up,
I trust you.
I trust me.
Everything's going to be like,
I really think that,
that this complaining thing is what's
going on.
So nobody likes to have people mad at
them,
you know?
And that's why people get mad at people.
This is why people get mad at people
over nothing.
They love to find someone who fucked up
and get mad.
Like we were talking about this
yesterday,
the Anthony Bordain casual response that
he had at the airport by TMZ that became
this huge thing where they said,
if you had a serve dinner to Kim Jong Un
and Donald Trump,
what would you serve?
He goes,
hemlock.
And they walked away,
which is hilarious.
Every time it's a job.
Well done.
And then I was reading all the responses
on tmz about,
you know,
uh,
get the secret service on him.
He's threatening Podesta,
you know,
like,
oh,
that's really where we,
it's like they,
if you are really offended by that
really offends you,
that you were a such a monumental pussy
that you deserve.
You don't deserve to have an opinion on
things like,
if that really bothered you to your
core,
I can't believe he's threatening potus.
Like,
you are such a fucking baby that you
shouldn't be allowed to talk about
things.
Your opinion,
it can't get in,
can't get in.
You're not allowed.
And there was hundreds of those people
that were commenting on the TMZ thing.
And I realized like this is just a
consequence of people being able to
communicate openly better.
So because of that,
you're getting so many moments that
they're feeling it and you're getting so
many people's opinions,
just you don't care for.
You don't want to hear you don't
appreciate or respect their intellect
and their spouting out nonsense.
But if you're a person who has to hear
that,
it hurts.
If you read something that's saying
someone's saying really mean Shit about
Katy Perry and her hair,
this fucking bitch thinks she's going to
appropriate black culture and this and
that.
Fuck you hoe.
And she starts reading that,
the panic that sets in thinking that
poor Katy Perry this.
There's bodyguards and fucking machine
guns looking out the windows and Katy
Perry's in her beverly hills mansion and
all these girls that I'll fucking cut
you.
Whoa.
Oh No,
they're gonna cut me.
Oh No.
She's like a little water balloon
walking around her.
Her Beverly Hills Mansion where there's
soft soft body worried that.
That's tough man.
This fucking bitch thinks she can take
our hair.
Bitch.
As she said.
She said that she's worried about that
stuff.
No,
I'm just making the scenario.
This is the drama.
Yeah.
It's so funny.
I mean like for me,
I read almost.
I'm almost all tweets like,
because there's not that many actually
in mentions.
Right?
So you read almost all the ones that
come to you.
You should never said that you've get
fucked up son.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I tell people,
I've told people that before.
Um,
I mean I'm not responding to all of them
and I might not get everyone,
but I'm just saying in general,
it's not that it's not that bad.
Like it's like I can,
I can actually read through a lot and
it's always interesting,
like if someone brings up a point,
sometimes they'll,
they'll attack it,
a really hostile angle.
Like at first they'll be like,
no,
you're not funny,
blah,
blah blah,
whatever,
whatever.
And I'll be like,
so I'll either do two things,
I'll either answer it in an interesting
way that kind of addresses their point
or um,
or I'll be like,
okay,
why do you feel this way?
And then talk about it and through a few
exchanges and oftentimes at the end of
it someone's like,
oh,
thanks for taking the time.
I'll be like,
oh yeah,
no problem.
I just wanted,
I was just wondering what you meant.
That's all I like.
I like criticism,
I don't mind criticism.
I'm not going to be like if I had a
shitty show and someone was like,
yeah,
it wasn't so great,
I'd be like,
you know what,
you're right.
It wasn't that great and which I love,
I love like having that dialogue and
just being like either open some things
I don't answer,
but you know,
most things,
most things I'll,
I'll,
if it's,
if it has a good point,
yeah,
I'll go for it.
Yeah.
I mean the ability to communicate with
people has its pros and cons for sure.
Absolutely.
It just does a lot of pros.
You've got to be able to,
you know,
you gotta you got to moderate yourself
and you've got to create some like some,
some filters and like understand like
how to just process something very
quickly and just be like,
is this worth energy or not?
Okay,
no energy when you're someone like Katy
Perry to you riding on this wave of
popularity.
I mean,
it's not to say that she's not talented.
She certainly is a talented singer and
performer.
Been a big part of who she is.
Relies on her attractiveness and her
cultural relevance.
Like how famous she is right now.
I mean,
she's,
she's not like,
we're not talking about like,
uh,
you know,
Liz phair cat power or someone who's
just like only doing their job.
Someone was only doing their shit and
you didn't like it.
He don't like it.
No.
She's a rock star.
She's a pop star through culture.
And when you,
what are you doing when you show me
$100?
Million followers or $100 million
followers on twitter?
Um,
I'd like you to do it.
Twitter audit on that because I'm not
buying 104.
I'll buy 80,
85.
The David Bowie images.
Pretty good.
Oh yeah,
I know,
right?
I guess it was probably really well done
in cultural appropriation.
Cap was.
She's got British Kareel.
Nope.
Mostly fake.
Wow.
Fifty 8 million.
Fake.
So she.
Katy Perry,
you fucking Hoe?
I don't mean that.
Katie.
I'm just joking around.
Don't get mad if we can sit on a couch
together with no shoes on and we'll work
through this.
Like you have your accounts fake have to
wear.
But afterward booties though.
Rugs.
Nowhere I'll,
I'll make everybody uncomfortable.
And where will the five finger vibrams
please never do that.
Where am all the time?
They never do it.
Forty three.
Never real.
Get some fake toast for the front of it.
Snap on.
And what did you say?
Forty 3 million real ones is a fucking.
No,
no,
it's not a lot.
Of course you would have said 44.
I would have been like absolutely
the 43.
Fuck that.
Listen.
Yeah.
I might not even be her fault.
It might be that she's so famous.
She attracts fake bots and accounts.
That's just joking around.
There was a thing recently about donald
trump's twitter followers went up by $30
million or some crazy shit.
Isn't it?
Something like that.
Like real quick people like those are
all bots.
Absolutely.
It's a artificial inflation.
Well that's like the king has no clothes
but.
Well,
you know,
uh,
the,
the thing before that,
what you were saying about I'm a pop
star,
like how you look in your relevance.
That's absolutely true.
And that's the thing I always feel for
in a way,
I feel for people that base their
careers on that because there is a way
you can always transition for sure.
It's rough,
like you could do it,
but um,
but when you're someone like Joni
Mitchell,
you know,
who both was very striking but,
but obviously involved in the music that
she made,
she was responsible for what she was
making and you knew that it was her,
her,
whereas a pop star is like,
I dunno,
they're using star gate from Sweden.
They're using the writing team,
they're using writing team from
Australia.
They're using like,
whatever.
You never know who's involved.
And sometimes maybe she writes her
because I know that she,
she was,
she plays guitar and writes original
music.
Well that's the thing about,
uh,
what's the skinny check back in back in
the day,
Taylor swift thing that people enjoy the
skinny check.
Sorry to.
The things that people really enjoy
about Taylor swift is that she is a
songwriter.
She writes her,
she composes her own stuff is the vast
majority of it was getting angry to ex
boyfriends.
But that's her prerogative.
Yeah.
He likes young Gal.
She's very sensitive.
She and that happened to break her heart
bed.
She write a song about you or someone
just might just because they want that.
They valued that over the relationships.
Yeah.
They would just go on for that.
Just getting,
trying to get that Kardashians thing
going on.
I'm trying to get a little fame off that
song.
Just throw some bad decker way.
Get her angry enough to put pen to
paper.
[inaudible] head.
It's a strat.
Should fuck you up with a song though,
Dude.
She comes hard.
Don't tell them.
Don't let it happen.
She throws haymakers sad about Joe and
John Mayer.
I mean Joni Mitchell did that right?
Sure.
Lot of our new carly Simon.
Carly Simon.
Yeah.
You're so vain.
You probably think this song is about
you.
You know.
So she,
she come on.
You've walked in to the party like you
were amazing.
So I mean people are mad.
She's not getting that good Dick.
And he's angry.
He's got other choices.
Angry.
He's decided to just live his life as a
sexual vagabond.
You can't just accept him for the freak,
they just let him just wander through
the world.
It's okay.
Like you had a brief time with them,
but no.
People,
when they,
they want to own their own each other,
you know,
he might've been vain.
He might've just been,
he might've just been a liar.
Oh yeah.
A bit annoying because then because then
it's like,
well,
it's not really about that a lot,
you know,
it's like,
uh,
what was the thing that happened with
Kevin Hart recently where he just got,
he just got in in.
He just got in front of it,
like there was a woman that he ended up
getting together with one night in Las
Vegas and the,
but uh,
it was kind of a team,
like kind of cat fished a little bit
too,
like they got a tape of him or something
like that.
And um,
this is me just hearing it from other
people.
So this is how informed I am.
But I will say the point is they tried
to extort him.
He just immediately this morning and
told everybody,
it's just like,
yeah,
I fucked up.
And she was like,
hey man,
as long as he comes back to me,
you know,
makes it,
makes feel.
I mean,
I'm totally paraphrasing everything but,
but what,
what for her it's like he didn't lie.
How fascinating is it that there's
people that would like to target him as
like an opportunity?
Like he's sort of wholesome in a way,
but also a funny,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What's so funny gaming,
they're going after MBA players and
athletes and nfl players just like that
to targeting them and like looking at
their instagram account now where
they're going to be.
Yeah,
just treat it as like a business
proposition.
It's like ransomware,
but it's the human hilarious.
It's a weird time where time.
It is a weird time for stuff like that.
You know?
It's a weird time for just,
just to enter the interaction that we
all have with each other.
It's just very strange.
You just like,
it's all like the possibilities of where
this go.
It used to seem like I kind of saw how
the world was going to go.
Can I remember like being a kid and
being worried about the war with Russia?
Remember that?
Do you remember like always being
worried that felt good.
It was a good kind of fear.
Felt good.
It was an established logic now,
but once that sort of dissolved,
I felt like I kind of had a sense at
least in some rough form of what the
future was going to be like,
things are going to get better,
people are going to get smarter,
life is going to advance and then all of
a sudden the internet came along and
then any ideas that I had had about what
the future was going to be like,
well now like,
Huh,
we'll fucking.
Who knows?
And it kept getting more.
And more who knows,
who knows that I'm at right now.
It's just like,
fuck man,
where is this going?
I really think it's going to some weird
virtual reality thing that people are
going to plug into and it's going to be
better than live.
Well yeah,
I mean it's,
you know,
it's,
we're designing a better interface for
it all the time,
but right now we're limited to like
little glowing rectangles.
We are,
but the kids that are super into video
games,
they're essentially experiencing it
right now just in a weird.
They're like right in front of the
screen,
like playing games.
That's what I'm doing.
Do you do that all the time?
Dude,
I had a,
an issue for a few years with quake
mine.
There you go.
It's just really fun.
Multiplayer.
But I,
I shy away from computer games now
because of that.
Too immersive to me.
Yeah Man,
I'm,
I'm not good at.
I'm not good at not doing things I enjoy
constantly.
Well my thing is I like for me it's kind
of like short stories,
so like binge watching.
Like I'll,
I'll choose the easiest setting and I'll
just play a game though where you're not
interacting with other people online.
Yeah,
I'm playing by myself or co op that my
thing is like I,
I think games.
This is something when you're talking
about like where's it going?
You know,
I think what will help and what I think
people really dig is I think people are
going to get tired of this first person
shooters.
Like it's always like shooters.
Shoot,
shoot,
explode,
explode suit.
I don't mind necessarily doing that.
I like it when it's more cartoony.
And so I'm a fan of borderlands.
It's kind of like this cool,
like a cel shaded.
It looks like you're playing a comic
book,
puzzle solving and stuff.
No,
it's a first person shooter with lots of
guns,
lots of explosions,
but everything is like cartoony and mad
maxy.
So it's not like crazy cartoony,
like just like comic book cards.
So.
So there's like this cool joyfulness to
it kind of video that I'd love to see
what that looks like.
Tickets in borderlands two.
I've seen a picture.
Ads I think.
Yeah,
at the mall when you walk by the video
games it kind of looks like a Mad Max
thing.
There's always like some guy with a gun,
he's got his fingers to his head,
like he's blowing his brains out and
then there's like some graphic,
like there you go.
Oh yeah,
dudes wearing a gas mask.
Cvs,
find the video yet.
See what this looks.
It's a really fun game and you can pull
this sucker.
Um,
I mean,
I don't,
I,
I'm playing divinity to right now.
I like it.
Well,
not that this is dope.
This is what it looks like when you're
playing it.
Someone playing it right now.
This is live at the top thing that
popped up.
Oh,
so we're watching someone live on
twitch,
but what he's doing,
why is it so compelling and it is
compelling,
but why is it so compelling watching
people play games?
It's hard to explain.
I think it's because,
um,
it's,
it's like a movie,
but it's,
it's,
it's simulates real time action.
Brian and from,
you know,
the first person point of view.
And so it's kind of exciting.
It's like,
did you ever see Hardcore Henry?
No,
I did not.
That movie is shot all first person I
heard it was awesome.
It's amazing.
It's some of the best fight stunt work
I've ever seen.
The choreography is insane and super
compelling.
I feel like my seven year old now,
like if I take my seven year old to a
restaurant and the TV's on,
they stare at the TV,
you know,
little kids like Stereo TV.
I feel like that like you're talking
about hardcore Henry.
Yeah,
probably.
Probably pretty cool.
But I'm able.
I'm just staring at this by now.
Okay.
Well this is also a weird level.
This is like some weird,
like extra thing.
This isn't the game because the game
looks even more like deserty cartoony.
This is like some like bonus,
whatever it is.
It's fucking awesome.
Oh yeah.
Use that one.
Like sanctuary.
I.
These are all people playing
on twitch.
Yeah.
Jesus.
I was hoping you're going to go to talk
about this game.
This is a new game that's gotten really
popular,
right?
They're a player in nouns,
battle grounds,
popular using twitch.
Really?
So this is a battle royale games.
So we're like the hunger games if you've
seen that for combat supply.
So like what can you.
Survival.
What,
what can you use?
You can use a gun or you drop 100
players drop into a map.
It's an island,
it's about five square miles encroaches
overtime,
circled comes in and starts killing you
as you come in to have to find
solicitor.
It's moving all of the guns and anything
you find in the map,
is it randomly placed around the map so
you're starting.
Everyone starts this scratch with just a
fist and your goal is to survive or play
hide and seek.
So either you become the bad ass that
kills everyone or jacked or are you just
hide and just survive to the end,
but meanwhile people are watching this
on twitch also.
It's kind of a popular thing to watch on
there too.
It makes sense though because like
you're seeing all these.
It's like watching a gladiator match.
Yeah,
but hold on.
If they're watching on
which can someone have a chat in the
other screen where the person is
playing,
can read the chat where people are.
I've been doing that recently and like
they can talk to me while I'm playing.
They get a tip.
Sometimes I'll miss something like I'll
just skip a scope and like,
hey,
you missed the scope or you missed that
awesome gun.
Go back and get it,
but my question is,
is it possible for them to also be
monitoring the other people in the game
and tell you where those people are?
It's not.
That's called stream sniping and that's
a cheating thing that's being handled
right now.
How's this being handled?
You can delay your stream a little bit.
You can hide different things that give
away your location on the map.
Like it's a setting that you can have.
Can you have a problem with people being
able to chat with each other a little
bit.
So like mighty mouse is actually doing
this too.
And he did a custom game with all of his
fans and 100 people that were just
watching him.
I jumped into we're all playing and to
and you'll just.
People end up going to attack them
because they wouldn't be the guy that
killed mighty mouse in the game or
whatever it is.
But like
I want to be the one to kill.
That's amazing.
He's gonna.
Yeah.
But the thing that I like,
I like co op games so I like fighting ai
with other humans.
Like,
you know,
like,
like people either like that or they're
coming because what I discovered when I
was playing,
um,
uh,
wait,
what was it called?
The game with the Max?
The new one?
Yeah.
Noodles.
Max Mixer.
A robot suits exoskeletons.
Okay.
But more like walking tanks.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
that's crazy.
It's like a hugely popular game,
but I was playing it and it's one of
those like massive multiplayer games.
And like every time it starts,
like there's all these people running
around and you don't know anybody.
You might might,
but I didn't and I would just get killed
within milliseconds.
Did you ever play fun?
Do you ever play unreal?
No.
Unreal tournament.
Yeah.
Well,
unreal and unreal tournament does.
That was another one that kind of.
Oh,
Gotcha.
What?
Quake.
Buck.
And they had all these crazy cool
weapons.
It's amazing graphics.
That's what these all are.
They're all,
they're all that.
It's like massive weapon systems.
You're switching weapons constantly.
You can craft weapons,
you can get,
you can collect ingredients.
Craft weapons like divinity to isn't
interesting.
Titanfall,
titanfall.
Oh yeah.
That's a huge game,
right?
Yeah,
it's in there,
it's gorgeous.
I love Mech suits,
like who doesn't like being,
like where you're talking about being
the hulk.
This is what you get to be like this
massive machine.
Um,
so it's,
it's,
it's really cool.
But I was just like so bad at it.
It was just to Lincoln and killed these
fucking kids today and it wasn't too
fun.
Games that I was like,
this is cool.
You know,
it's,
it's cool to imagine you know,
yourself in these situations is cool.
But I also like playing cooperatively.
So if I was doing this,
playing with other players and um,
I had a team,
I guess that would be something I would
try being on a team against other human
beings just so fucking much time.
You have to take your life to play
these.
Here's,
here's the thing that you might get into
warehouse scale.
Our RPG vr vr rpgs.
Oh,
I've heard of that.
Yeah,
I've heard they're there.
They're trying to set up.
Wasn't,
wasn't there a place that was doing a
virtual reality in Utah?
Wasn't like in Utah.
Oh,
you think it's Salt Lake City?
The Toy?
Yeah,
they're setting up a whole like
environment.
Yeah,
they have one set up.
it's great.
They did the ghostbusters thing at
Madame tussauds wax museum in New York
for the ghostbusters.
Yeah.
The future of virtual reality.
It's magazine.
It's crazy.
Like you wear a backpack is a backpack
computer,
so your wireless and then they have
custom goggles that they fit on.
You look at this shit and,
and all of this is mapped in an
environment.
So you're holding the guns,
you look down,
you see the gun,
the gun moves when you move it.
So these people are walking through
sentencing environment.
This is insane.
Yeah.
So that's so,
so it's mapped.
So this is what you're seeing in the
rain and so certain things,
you know,
it depends on how one to one.
Uh,
I hope that in the future with real time
data capture,
with cloud capture,
you'll be able to pick up objects,
like it'll actually be able to track of
teddy bear and you reach out and the
teddy bears there.
It's lined up well.
So you can naturalists grab it,
you squeeze it.
And in real time,
the,
the system is reading it,
so it's actually puppeting all the
objects in the room.
Um,
so yeah,
and then the floor rumbles,
their steam that comes out,
you know,
kind of like a wide.
But you are the visual component year to
hijack.
So right now is just ghostbusters.
Is that what it is?
Ghostbusters and the void?
The void is,
I think it's public.
Um,
I think you can go there.
yeah.
So the void,
but there's a place that's opening up
hopefully in,
in Los Angeles,
which is totally right for it.
[inaudible].
There's a huge community here that Santa
Monica.
Yeah.
Really?
There's like a,
at least like five major players,
um,
in like Santa Monica area,
major players.
What do you mean by major player people
as humans are the time players like
weaver?
Um,
you know,
they have stars.
Uh,
they have,
they have titles that they're working on
and they have,
they have experiences,
you know,
what some people call simulations
experiences,
interactive experiences,
um,
or just like puzzles or whatever.
Like this.
People innovating for Vr.
So their company,
their production companies that make
videos,
they think in code,
they are,
they code,
they create software or they're just
really good at capturing.
There's like,
you know,
Adi,
which does like spherical capture,
um,
or uh,
or volumetric capture,
it's called.
Yeah.
So there's a lot,
a lot of people here,
so the technology is here and it's
always being innovative,
but warehouse scale is the perfect
marriage for people,
especially in La who liked to be active
and might feel weird about sitting down
in a chair and just staring at a screen,
the controller in their hand,
but they can understand naturalistic
movement and you can in warehouse scale,
you can actually see the size of the
room and feel the breadth of the space.
So in that particular video it seemed
like they had chairs and tables and
everything like that,
but the actual textures on those chip,
that was all added later.
Yes.
All the objects were real.
But they look some of the projects,
some of the objects,
like the major obstacles are there.
Yeah.
The table share was crazy because they
have a chair in the video game that was,
it seemed to me to be very different.
Like the bridge.
Totally.
That's what I mean.
It's not,
it's not one to one.
It's just like,
it's just a basic representation,
but saying in the future you'll actually
be able to just have like a movie set
and the system will be able to.
We will already have a preloaded pre
scanned sized version of that room,
but then there'll be sensors that are
real time calibrating it to make sure
that it's rock solid.
So when you reach out you're like,
oh,
I don't feel like I had to move my hand
a little higher to grab this.
You can just reach out and it's right
there and it's a one for one
representation.
Do you think that the chair is very low
to the ground?
Wow.
Look at these people walking through
there.
Whereas this,
if they're doing that,
uh,
this was called Vr studio vr arcade.
This might've been a.
yeah,
ferk iteration and yeah,
this is fucking insane in the future,
man.
It's going to be really,
really weird.
I mean,
it's going to be so weird.
imagine like if the mapping becomes so
like rock solid that you could reliably
run up a flight of stairs.
Oh my God,
that's so crazy.
I mean that sounds like sounds like a,
but it's like it's not.
It's not.
And then once it comes becomes wireless.
I mean remember when the only way to get
internet,
the only way to get to the Internet was
to have an Ethernet cable connected to
your device.
Right?
That's silly.
I don't have anything to cable anywhere.
No,
I know where to get one.
The only.
The only problem with Vr is that the
processing power.
So for awhile it had to be tethered to a
PC.
Now they have pc backpacks.
Well now I guarantee you what they're
going to have is a like one of those,
you know,
you get one of those five charge battery
packs for a phone where you can recharge
your totally going to get one of those
bitches.
It's going to hook up to your phone and
everything is going to take place.
All the processing is going to be on
your phone,
you're going to have a bluetooth headset
and you're going to be able to go out
into a park and do this.
It'll be like Bluetooth five,
15 point.
Oh yeah.
Like you and your friends.
You'll just have to walk across the
park.
Like you remember when you first got an
iphone and you had to do the fingerprint
a bunch of times.
I can also do sorts of different ways
the side of the front and the back.
That's what you'll have to do.
You're like,
okay,
define your parameters are out in the
park and everybody will walk to the park
together and criss cross.
And then once the computer has enough
data,
they go,
okay,
processing the game begins in 10,
and then your Avatar just transforms.
Let's see.
That's the thing.
It's like,
you know,
uh,
you have augmented reality and virtual
reality and augmented reality is
interesting with Microsoft's Hololens
uses this real time.
I'm basically can see the environment
around it,
wrapping it so it stereoscopically maps
it and it creates a really quick texture
map of the environment that you're in.
So imagine that mixed with like the idea
behind the,
I forget the name of the project,
but it was a early Microsoft project
where it took,
it's basically scraped all relevant
types of photos and stitch them together
and created a virtual three d
environments of locations based on
photographs that are everywhere on the
Internet so it could recreate a plaza in
Italy.
Um,
and then using like kind of
interpolation,
like the AI software kind of stitching
it together,
blah,
blah blah.
So imagine that existing already just
because people are passing by with their
phones.
They're taking pictures or taking
videos.
So all of that data is now president
according to the location that you're
at,
mixed with headsets that are able to
scan in real time collectively that also
gets processed and stitch together,
cross together so that instantaneously
you can have a mapped almost one for one
game zone and a giant park.
Like pretty quick.
And just like how you described it.
But like using things that are in the
headset that are tracking in real time
and then transmitting it or at that are
completely internal to the headset and
then also networked intelligence to
simultaneously.
And then also probably some fake stuff
that they can create visually.
And with three d sound totally see like,
you know,
if you're doing an Avatar game,
you see the dragons flying overhead,
you're like,
well that's the Hololens does that.
It's got these two little slits.
They're not even like regular speakers.
Their slips that are above your ears
that are pointed down.
It's like a almost like hypersonic
sound,
you know,
like sound.
That can be basically paper thin.
So if I move the access you can't hear
it.
And then if I move it back on access and
you haven't moved your head,
you'll hear it specifically in one tiny
slice of audio.
And so it has to be very precise.
So it's a form of that,
but they're just pointing down and they
can simulate dolby five point one by
normally just saying think about house
crazy.
Like your,
your,
your earplugs are right.
Yeah.
Like look at this little tiny ass
speaker.
Yup.
There's little tiny ass speaker when
it's in your ear.
I mean you can get too loud.
Like if I listened to.
If I listen to music sometimes it can
get too loud with these.
Then I got to get you better had
headphones.
These are great.
They're,
they're good.
What's wrong with them?
They're the ones that come with the
iphone.
Yeah.
They're,
they're okay.
They just,
they have a lot of high end which is not
good for your hearing.
Oh,
not good for your hair.
I like things that are soft on my ears,
but I can hear clearly.
It's about what?
Precision.
What does this fuck this?
Fuck your ears up.
I would say like.
Sure.
Really?
It depends on what you're using for the
ear pods.
[inaudible] actually sounded really
fucking great.
Yeah.
So I like the ear pods are better.
I like them better than the headphones
that come standard.
Anytime headphones are included,
they're like,
they're,
they're okay,
but they're not great.
I mean on an apple standard better than
most.
But uh,
the earpods or more precise,
the earpods just sound natural.
They'd sound like I'm really surprised
I'm prepared for them not to sound good.
Almost every time they use them,
but they sound great because they're
not.
They don't seal the ear,
they sit in the ear,
but the design is so ingenious that even
when I'm working out I'm like,
I'm like on the bench,
getting up,
jumping around.
They're still not falling out and they
sound great.
The bass sounds all natural and then
I'll put it in like a high end pair.
I have like a crazy amount of headphones
and I'll put in some like crazy
headphones,
like some odd days,
whatever plan or magnetic blah bullshits
like little tiny ones that don't require
much power of phone would power it fine,
but I put those in and I'm like,
Oh wow,
that sounds really small.
Like I have to adjust to its detail.
Whereas the IPODS,
like as soon as I put them in like,
oh,
that's just.
Sounds like a nice perfect frequency
curve.
Feels very flat in real.
Wow.
That's a strong endorsement.
Pretty good.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm really.
I was very impressed with them.
I bought them and I never opened the
box.
Really?
They're easy to pair man and it's cool
because I just had them in my jeans all
the time.
Oh,
right.
A little easier to handle in this wire.
That wire gets fucked up.
Yeah.
He just like,
I just pulled it out and it's so fun
because the way it snaps closed and open
magnetically.
So satisfying.
How long is the battery?
Life lasts a little suckers.
I think it's eight hours real,
I think with the case.
The charge case recharges right there.
Whether their parents,
the Apple Watch.
I have the new Apple Watch.
Did you get the three l,
t e l series three.
And what's the deal with the three?
What's,
what's better?
Lte now you can leave your phone at
home.
Yeah,
just take your watch.
Yeah.
Comfortable enough with your life to do
that.
I mean if I'm going to a concert or
something like that,
like you know,
I mean I,
you know,
I think what's great about this and when
I saw people talking about like,
what do you think about the Apple Watch
when they first announced it,
there was so many people that are like,
it's so stupid.
You already have a phone.
Why do you need a,
you know,
why does your watch needs to be a phone?
And they're saying all these things
related to that.
And I'm like,
guys,
you don't get it.
It's about having to not manage a
physical object.
It's the watch is on your wrist.
It just stays on your wrist the whole,
the whole day.
I mean unless you take it off or
whatever,
but most of the time you just leave it
on the whole day.
And it's always there.
You don't have to manage it.
Like if you want to make a call,
you make a call.
If you want to take call,
you know you have your,
your pods,
you can do a phone call,
you can listen to your music on it.
How much power battery wise is that
thing have?
I think on Lte,
what is it?
Like six,
five hours,
something like that.
What do you live in a half a day.
You get it.
So that thing works better.
Yeah,
that's like all lte bit.
But realistically you're not going to be
on lte all the time,
so depending on your usage it,
it'll,
I think it'll last.
I mean is that five hours of talking?
I think of yet lte,
like talking or something like that.
But I think for me I'm like around 67,
74 percent every day.
Really at the end of every day.
So I can go a couple days without
charging it actually.
Ooh,
boom.
Move though.
I know I liked it.
I like it.
Feel like a rebel,
like pushing it man.
I'm no wireless pads are going to be
everywhere soon enough.
We're using it on my phone or the watch
rather.
I just got the eight plus and just set
it right on there.
So you're going to get the 10 as well.
Are you a hedonist?
Crazy person.
I have like,
I have like almost every top phone
because I want to know android because I
haven't,
I have a t mobile account and a t and t
account.
So you want to learn android so you're
fucking around with it.
So I'm always updating.
I just want to know how the,
like what,
what's the Ui philosophy like?
What do they think is interesting
because they're too,
they're too divergent,
but they're very similar.
I like to check out like,
oh,
what's the difference?
Um,
that's really frustrating that I fund
doesn't do that.
That's frustrating that this doesn't do
that,
you know?
Um,
if it wasn't for airdrop airdrops kind
of keeping me on board,
like I realized how much I liked that
once I tried the Google Pixel,
which I really liked.
Yeah,
that's a great fun,
great phone and the Pixel two supposed
to be even better.
But yeah,
the Samsung Galaxy note eight might be
the best phone in the world.
They say,
yeah,
I have the eight of the eight plus it's
very beautiful note plus as a.
no,
I'm not going to.
Yeah,
galaxy eight plus.
Yeah.
But the note is a similar same thing,
but it's got the obviously the style and
there's a couple other features.
I think the cameras the same,
but it's just got a couple extra
features.
So I just stick with the smaller.
What do you think about it?
Plus the eight plus.
Yeah,
I love it.
The screen is gorgeous.
Amazing,
right?
It is.
So it's.
The colors are just insane.
It's really beautiful.
And once you have no bevel,
yeah.
You look at it.
Yeah.
Is it basil?
Basil.
Why don't say bevel?
You might've said something you grew
because it's soft enough of a v.
I was like,
he said Bezel,
but it just sounded weird through.
I call myself
out on it.
That's a good job man.
But that he did so much more beautiful
than seeing that edge.
That edge is like the obvious edge of
the bottom of the iphone where your
fingerprint scanner goes and the top of
the iphone where the speaker is the
chin.
It looks clunky.
Yeah.
It's totally clunky and it's,
you know,
it's,
it's weird.
It's the next step before a augmented
reality glasses so that your phones or
your phone or your glasses.
When I look at the note,
eight red band as the note eight,
it looks like minority report.
I'm looking at this.
I'm like,
wow.
Like that was a whole.
That's a whole screen.
Yeah.
You're holding the screen.
It's all screen.
This is the future.
It's pretty Rad.
Yeah.
It legitimately feels to me like a big
step up from like a regular phone.
I look at that and I'm like,
okay,
that's.
This is obviously next level.
Yeah.
I got the essential phone too.
Just to see what that display was like
to kind of get a preview for the iphone
10.
Iphone 10 is going to be insane.
It's going to blow it all.
It looks.
It looks great.
I mean I will say that their product
design has been like,
there was a period where I'm like,
Eh,
like what?
Just kind of like their last few
iterations of computer.
I mean,
I always get the new,
I get the new everything from apple
pretty much and then just either sell or
like find like someone who needs a
computer or whatever,
just give it to them.
But uh,
so I cycled through a lot of technology.
Um,
and just for awhile they know the,
the laptops were,
they were cool,
they were like some nice improvements.
I mean I like the,
you know,
the macbook pro design is pretty cool.
I like the Strip.
I thought it was going to be a gimmick.
The strip becomes an issue with me
because I have fat fingers and sometimes
I hit.
Oh yeah,
I just stopped.
So I just stable secrets for,
for the,
for the laptop now.
But I did too,
but we didn't matter when you hit the
button and release a series.
I know what I'm talking about.
That's me.
But it's also,
it's,
it's right there.
It's right there where the fucking
delete key.
His finger slips and goes up there.
Yes.
It falls in there.
Boom.
Would you like to enable Siri know you
bench seats cancel?
Nope.
Just just learn.
You know what I mean,
just I didn't want me to technology to
learn better.
It's not learning very well.
The thing about being able to switch
windows on the bar is kind of
interesting,
but quite honestly I never used it
either.
Never used it.
I would prefer mechanical buttons for
sound too.
I agree with that.
I it's way faster,
way faster.
You have to press it once and then you
have to press it again and then just
said just the sound.
Why don't have it?
Just a process of mine is like normal.
I know there's probably a keyboard
combine you can use.
I think it's our command,
apple or plus.
The only other complaint that I would
have is I really like a tactile
mechanical feeling keyboard when I
write,
oh,
particular bigger keyboard,
a bigger key.
A throw traveling like this one because
it's.
I liked this new Mac book pro better
than the last Mac book pro because the
last one was kind of mushy a little bit
and this one is more like it.
It seems like real positive feedback
when it clicks and what I really like is
the Lenovo thinkpads,
they amazing keyboard
that works like you feel where the keys
are.
It's like I type faster with it.
It just feels like more surgery.
Yeah.
My fingers just can communicate with it
better.
Yeah.
These are like flat,
like flat rectangle.
They're not very high off the ground
either,
so because of the fact they're not very
high off of the rest of the keyboard.
You're not sure what you're touching
sometimes socially if you have calluses
I guess.
And fingers.
Yeah,
so you have to just understand the
spacing of it,
but it's almost like they're preparing
you for typing on a glass screen the
same way you type on your iphone and and
see.
I'm not a big fan of that.
I think we should be able to speak to
our computers and they go,
Ooh,
you can just get a keyboard.
Do you touch to,
okay,
I don't want that.
I wanted this.
This is the whole thing for a laptop in
the first place.
Totally sent me a screen and a keyboard.
Yeah,
totally.
Fuck you.
Do I though,
do you,
do you have an echo or any of those
things?
Yeah,
I got an echo of never set it up,
don't use it,
so gave it to me as a gift.
I get it,
but just sitting there and I go,
I totally get that.
But I will say I use it for my lights in
my house is really nice.
Um,
so as I'm going to bed I'll just fit
like computer turn lights off.
Can you,
can you change the way you talk to it?
Can you say shut the lights off bitch?
No,
I wish.
See it needs to do that.
Yeah,
I need to be able to do that,
but it's going to get there.
Don't worry.
It's coming.
These lights and then you can set it up.
Know.
But I'm just saying like you can speak
to it super fast so I can say like I'm
in the living room and I want the lights
off.
I'll just say computer a computer,
turn the living room lights off and just
walk away and he gets it.
It's like immediately on,
it's like,
it,
it hears that,
that prompt.
It's on,
I'm saying the sentence
naturalistically.
I'm not saying,
Hey,
Siri.
Yeah.
How many times have I gone to the
bathroom today?
Did it?
You've got.
I'm sorry.
I don't know the answer to that.
Whatever that long.
It's that long.
Why would I buy the I?
There's just no.
There's no reason for me to use
something that takes that fucking long
to process.
It's faster to do voice dictation in,
in a google APP,
right?
That you're gonna get.
So it's.
But that's a combo.
It's like the voice did better in the
Google apps.
Is it better?
It is better.
It said their algorithms are better,
like the artificial intelligence is a
little bit better note keeping and stuff
as well.
Yeah,
I mean there's.
You can do a little bit more with Google
assistant than you can with Siri also.
I liked the name.
I don't.
I hate it when they name on ais thing
like Cortana for Microsoft.
I'm like,
I don't fucking,
I don't want to like get it.
I like Cortana.
She's great.
I love Halo.
However,
I don't need a personality.
I want it to be a computer and I want to
just do what I'd like it to do.
I don't need to hear like,
okay,
you know,
the sunlight today is really beautiful,
but I'd watch that wear some sunscreen
unless I wanted that.
I want that option.
But I also want it to be neutral.
So over time I want ai to learn what I
dig and just kind of do that.
Yeah,
there should be an option for whether or
not you want it to behave like a corny
human.
Yes,
I know some people.
I mean I get it.
You want something like that?
You want like a little friend or
something?
I get it.
I do that.
I do.
I'd have like a couple of different
versions of it,
you know,
if,
if I'm in work mode,
I changed it to like computer voice if
I'm just chilling,
having a good time with friends and
changed it to hey party person voice.
Hey.
All right.
That sounds like a great idea.
Hey,
play some miles.
Davis.
You know what I was just thinking too,
that name.
It sounds like a great choice.
That's really as man what as you get.
Yeah.
Like man,
if you get like John Lee Hooker's voice.
Yeah,
that'd be great.
Talk to John Lee Hooker.
Everywhere you go,
you get like a.
You get linguists and language experts
and mimics to like all sit down and
create a program so they can.
It can actually do impersonations off of
like inputting it on audio so it could
actually become that person.
Look with Jamie just pulled up
library.
Liar.
Bird firebird allows you to create a
digital voice.
That sounds like you.
One minute.
That's awesome.
That's insane.
Photoshop for voice thing essentially
that are available for you can make your
own.
Just got to read.
I love it.
It's very good.
Is it?
Feel like fuck with it though.
That's what I want to.
If you have 40 minutes of your audio,
they.
They basically have you
demo stuff I think.
Does Donald Trump's voice here?
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh my God,
no way.
Love Him.
H is considering in addition to other
options,
stopping all trade with any country
doing business with North Korea.
That's.
That's fine.
You know,
do you know,
you know that it's him.
You can tell it's synthesized,
but you know that attempt.
It sounds amazing though.
It's pretty great
meeting General Kelly,
General Maddis and other military
leaders at the White House to discuss
North Korea,
but the middle section was nice.
The front of the
backward not very good.
Well,
I wonder if they're adding that
reverberation.
That weird.
If it thinks that's part of the audio,
like the quality of the water from
they're doing that on purpose because
you're talking about the president,
like can you do an audio version of the
president and pretend like that.
Like you might get in real trouble
because that audio could be used.
Like if he never actually said that
about not doing business with North
Korea.
If they didn't make an obviously fake
version.
It's pretty.
It's pretty fun.
Another language,
another person.
It's pretty terrible.
I'm gonna.
Run to the restroom real quick.
Oh,
go ahead.
Go play me some Broccoli.
I think they're taking tweets and
putting that through it.
Oh,
okay.
Let's hear it.
Thank you to all the first responders
and people helping each other out.
It sounds terrible.
We do as Americans,
why is it sounds so terrible to on this.
You're a.
The way they have it set up like if you
and me did it today,
they have specific sentences that we
would need to read to hit the syllables
and I think they're taking speeches and
they probably tried to find the words as
opposed to going directly into their
computer program which was built for
the.
The only issue though is it doesn't
sound good.
Those don't because they didn't actually
have Obama reading specifically for them
into their car.
They just took speeches probably and
found the words that matter,
but even if they took speeches,
it sounds so much shittier than the
actual speech itself.
I'm just going to close my friend who
showed it to him.
He said he did it himself and got really
surprised that he just typed a sentence
then and was like,
holy shit,
that sounds like me.
They're going to be able to have people
saying all kinds of crazy things.
This is a.
This is not the Adobe Photoshop when
this is I think a small company,
so they're probably going to.
Adobe's got a better make people have
feuds with people by saying a little.
You hear what you said about your man.
She was with this pretty fucked up and
they're like,
what?
We'll fuck him and then that guy says
fuck him and so some crazy shit about
him and the next thing you know the
reality,
a TV show editing trick rich just said
off camera and you show somebody as
reaction to what they heard and can send
that to your friend and be like,
look,
they're fucking pissed at you.
And then just really easily.
That could be an APP on your phone.
Just like that app where you put a puppy
dog nose on it.
How's it any different.
As soon as someone gives the green light
to put that on the apple store,
the Google play store,
someone's going to figure out a way to
to use that to make weird copies of
people do have ethics.
So,
oh,
there's ethics.
Get the fuck out of here with your
ethics.
Shut up once you pee in the pool,
you're not extracting that stuff out and
stop,
or at least they have samples.
They released a public awareness.
Yeah.
First,
to raise public awareness,
to make people realize that technology
exists by releasing audio samples from
the digital voices of Donald Trump and
Barack Obama.
Second,
we want to ensure that your digital
voice is yours.
We are the stewards of your voice,
but you control its usage.
No one can use it without your explicit
consent.
Shut your whole shy or whole.
That's like saying,
I can hold my breath forever.
Shut up.
No,
you can't.
You can't control that.
They have some wonky as website where
they're trying to pretend like they can
control the digital voice that gets
printed using their app like the fuck
you can this,
this.
Once you've made some technology like
this is all your silly words that you're
writing down,
that doesn't mean anything.
You're what are you going to violate?
All the laws,
the known laws of technological
progression with your disclaimer and
release.
That's not.
Yeah.
It's not really possible because they
can.
They can tell through an analysis that
means,
I mean that's.
That sounds like you were in that part
of the synthesis.
That's like,
that's the computer.
That's the best it can do right now.
For now,
for sure it's going to get better and
for sure they're not going to be able to
control it.
Like once it's gotten to that stage,
it's that crazy.
I just think it's a matter of time
before we have no idea what the fuck is
real and it's not at that point.
Why not just hire an Obama impersonator?
Well,
not as good because it Obama
impersonator.
Even the best Obama impersonators just
affects similarly.
You know,
there's such a.
So you're saying that the.
But the computer has to.
I mean,
unless it's just audio being played
back,
it's like simulating it.
Oh you mean like a physical video?
That'll be easy.
They'll definitely video.
They've already done it with video.
What do you want me screaming over
there?
Bottom of the site,
they had this little disclaimer
agreement regarding biometrics.
I collect it and right here it's how we
disclose biometric data.
We may also disclose biometric data in
the following circumstances,
law enforcement agencies,
putting a warrant and Cetera,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Wow.
Oh Wow.
So you basically.
It's.
This is all CIA psyops man.
The fucking same people keeping the man.
He let your neck keeping the man the
play with the fucking APP map first.
They got their fingerprints,
man,
your fingerprints off your phone data,
fast data.
They're collecting DNA from your
screens.
When you turn your phone and data is
being stored on a third party server,
which I mean,
it says it right.
Oh,
we're fucked.
All that data's going to get scooped up
by the Russians.
The Russians are going to have all these
people talk and shit.
They're gonna have.
They're going to have heads of industry
talking shit about Donald Trump,
threatening to kill him.
Donald trump's going to get crazy
paranoid because he doesn't read.
And next thing you know,
fucking nuclear war going on in the
United States.
Donald trump is bomb and bill gates,
Mark Zuckerberg,
he's just a fucking hire massage to
protect him and his mansion because he
feels that donald trump's trying to
assassinate him because he wants to be
president.
Oh my God.
I vote for Zuckerberg.
Don't know man.
Dude made facebook.
He wins.
They didn't even make it.
Apparently I didn't watch that movie.
When they say facebook know facebook,
I think.
I think he's still a little but not so
much as like someone who might be in a
band and they break up and they make a
song and that was kind of based on some
riffs,
you know,
that someone was say.
It's like,
well,
it's hard.
Did he steal it?
A little like Chris Walks,
ex wife steals money from him.
Do that by just going to court and
stealing it just publicly.
Well,
you know what they do.
You get divorced.
They're like,
I want it.
Ah,
you motherfucker.
Oh,
I know your money is.
I heard bill or Chris Act.
I.
Eddie.
Yeah.
Eddie Murphy would definitely talk about
that a lot.
Oh yeah.
Well,
Eddie Murphy was talking about with
Johnny Carson.
Remember Johnny Carson and give up like
hundreds of millions dollars to some
chick he was briefly having sex with and
Whoa,
whoa.
Be.
I mean not briefly,
but his entire life.
He to her,
whatever that meant.
Equally tell fucking single joke wasn't
an even deal.
But that stealing,
stealing,
stealing too.
So did he steal in that way?
Let Johnny Carson's wife still not May.
No,
I,
I think,
I think that he just had,
he had an idea of what to do with it so.
And that's.
But I don't think that he's necessarily.
I mean that can be proven wrong,
but I don't think he's necessarily an
innovator in any way at the key refined
an idea that was pretty obvious right in
my space had already existed.
Right.
So people would register.
Yeah.
Who the fuck used friendster?
I did.
Jamie was one of the top dog.
I love France.
Shamiana.
Friendster tee shirt were everywhere.
Go to friends who now?
It's so sad.
It's sad.
It's,
it's,
yeah,
it's still there,
but it's owned by somebody might spill.
Spill still exists as well.
I'm thinking of going back to my Spanish
man.
I don't know,
there's to be something else.
I think I could bring it back.
I don't think you could.
I mean,
but why would you want to friends still
live in the.
I'm kidding.
Friendster living the gang of friendster
is taking a break.
The redesigned friendster came about
through enduring passion to make a
difference over the what?
Make a difference.
Make a difference in your bank account.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Over the years,
we have built a vibrant community and
received valuable support and
encouragement.
However,
due to the evolving landscape and are
challenging industry,
the online gaming,
online,
online gaming community did not engage
as much as we had hoped for.
[inaudible]
profound development in gaming in the
gaming industry has also led us to
rethink our strategic priorities.
We have dust made,
the decision to take a break and pause
our services.
Effective June 14,
2015 break kids.
You quit two years ago.
You fuck quit.
Quit.
Quit two years in.
You've got to say like if you know,
if you and your girlfriend had taken a
break,
it's been two years.
You're not taking a break anymore.
No.
Right.
You guys have seen each other in two
years.
Yes.
It totally fits.
Pretty safe over friendster.
And then for the Internet,
I mean multiply that times 10,
maybe someone's going to come out with a
new one of virtual reality,
augmented reality based.
Well altspace almost happened was that I
was working with them and what they were
doing,
standup comedy and like a,
it's basically like a facebook of Vr,
so social vr and uh,
that was really fun and they really
helped out amazingly well.
They were like the coolest.
They're really cool.
Justin reuland and I hung out when they
night together in a graveyard with like
500 other fans and we just fucked around
for an hour and 40 minutes.
He was at his house with a small team of
people,
making sure he was all good and he had
uh,
he had uh,
a motion capture suit,
a motion sensor suit and uh,
yeah it is.
And that's me doing stand up.
So that's why I'm moving that character.
That's crazy in my living room.
Just like,
hey guys,
I mean that,
that easily could take the place of
touring.
Yeah,
they had some toys where you can
interface and you could be on stage in
front of and even if you.
How about this,
that people go to a place and the people
actually go to a theater and you just
get live themed into the theater.
You don't have to be there with some
concerts.
Right?
Like a live broadcasts like simulcasts
did it in theaters.
Yeah,
like rolling stone or something like
that.
It was different than a hologram.
No,
no,
that's different than like,
get immersive vr.
Oh,
did that rapper chief Keef event?
And they were saying like he couldn't go
because there's going to be riots and
whatnot.
So they agreed to do was have them be a
hologram.
Oh yeah,
they did that little curve scrying
projection because people don't
like him.
No.
Just uh,
he's a,
he incites the crowds I guess.
I don't know,
just silly.
Very lit when he performs.
He's a,
he's crazy fellow,
right?
He's a wild one.
Yeah.
That chief Keef.
I've seen him on the instagram.
Yeah,
he's a young,
crazy rapper.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
He's one of the wild,
wild child.
Very aggressively.
Crazy ones.
So they had him as a hologram on stage.
So there's real people at the show and
let me hear this.
Whoa.
This is so strange.
Yeah.
They've been doing in Japan for awhile.
They have like pop stars,
artificial intelligence.
It seems like he has to stand in one
place.
Yeah.
I think the hologram thing Kinda sorta
like the will I am situation.
Remember he couldn't or you can't like
walk around the room but you can talk to
someone.
Wow.
Yeah.
So weird.
The Japanese technology,
but it's like an obvious curved huge
screen.
Can you imagine if you went somewhere to
watch a hologram?
You'd be so angry with the person,
isn't there?
Can you be there and you know,
you have to be weird to go somewhere
publicly and then to watch a hologram.
I feel like it's the future though,
unless it's someone who doesn't live
anymore.
Right?
Like Tupac,
like when they did,
they'd made Tupac way more jacked than
it really is.
Do you notice that?
No.
Yeah.
Then they did the Tupac one.
They had them like a crossfit Tupac.
Tupac was in insane shape.
He really looked like floyd mayweather.
That's.
Yeah,
because he was a pretty pretty wired
look at them.
Look at them.
Oh No.
Yeah.
Come on dude.
Now these Super Jack Tupac,
Tupac that's doing Jujitsu five times a
week,
right?
That tupacs got a six pack.
He's got big muscles.
Is that buck?
Was that really?
Is that video footage?
Yeah,
this is from Coachella,
but they've made it holographic.
No,
but I mean the.
The footage there,
did the generate it?
Oh,
they generate.
It's.
This is all.
Yeah.
This is all CGI body double.
Was it a body double?
Oh,
well that's part of the problem.
They use some body double who jacked.
She should have told that dude's got to
lay off the weights for a couple years
if you want to play Tupac.
Yeah,
because I don't think they would've been
able to track his performance in the
nineties.
Well,
this guy who they used the body that
will,
they got overzealous because he's way
too big.
I mean he's like 20 pounds heavier.
Right?
I'm not exaggerating.
I think he was wired.
He was wired with this guy.
This guy's Jack an MMA fighter.
He's pulling tyron woodley almost
tonight.
They have a side by side.
This captain Jack?
Yeah,
he's getting.
He's built like George St Pierre.
Like that's a good.
That's a good comparison.
Not Quite tyron woodley levels,
but pretty fucking jacked.
You got a side by side.
They don't have one.
I'm trying to ponder.
The fate just came up,
said it wasn't actually
a Hologram and I'm trying to think.
Oh,
what they're saying,
what that means,
what CGI generated.
Then special effects studio made it.
Yes.
Expensive CGI.
Yeah.
See that's what I was saying.
So maybe they used a body double the
track,
the movements and then they got
overzealous when they went to give him
six packs and packs and just like they
made a star,
a star wars figurines or like all
jacked.
They're all super muscular.
Yeah.
It was like,
what the fuck you skywalker's jagged?
Yeah.
It was like it was like late nineties
star wars or something like that.
Yeah.
It's like super hero bullshit,
but people wanted superhero bullshit
back then.
Like if you tried to put out a figurine
of someone who wasn't jacked,
people used to superhero figurines,
so it's just so dumb though.
It's like,
I want something that looks like the
thing.
I don't want to fucking cheat because
otherwise it looks cheap.
It looks lazy.
Just Lazy.
There's what?
Yeah,
but that's not going to be one where he
doesn't have his shirt off his shirt to
show the thug life tattoo.
Yeah.
You got to get the whole.
The guy.
That guy's way more jacked.
Trust me.
Oh,
there you go.
Yeah.
See,
I mean come on,
just get the smaller waist because why?
He looks like a lightweight boxer.
Yeah.
That's what he lives in shape for sure.
He's definitely in shape.
He's not fat,
but like that,
that.
I mean,
come on.
That guy's super duper jacked.
Yeah.
I don't know where they got those
proportions is from.
You're going to be that jacked.
Like you really have to not eat
anything.
That's bullshit.
Oh,
I know.
Like you can't be fucking around at all.
Not even slightly.
No.
It's just like,
oh,
like straight protein,
super cleanly.
Just Broccoli.
Chicken breast,
egg whites,
no beers?
No.
No,
not one beer at all.
No.
Like a water,
no salt,
no salt.
Uh,
and in fact one day you'll probably fast
or you'll like overwater like by gallons
and gallons.
Then not drink for two days.
Probably take diuretics before you do
this shit.
Retics.
Yet they made one.
Uh,
you wouldn't,
would you let them add a little bit
extra water weight or no fucking
slimming down?
Say leave me at the way.
Um,
they already did.
I'm in real life.
Fight in real life and we got to watch
it.
You'd be,
I guess either way the fuck I am man.
Don't make me look more muscular than I
really am.
It's more immersive.
Yeah.
And the EA video game,
that's my actual body.
They took fucking hundreds of pictures.
They have you stand,
they rotate around you with a camera.
They have this thing that spins around
you and takes photos of all these
different precise angles.
You have to do all these different
things with your body.
You have to do things with your arms.
You have to stand with your hands up,
you have to extend your fists.
He had the doing the doing the
combination,
volumetric capture and optical capture.
That's what actually.
So they skin you.
There you go.
The skin they put,
they basically skinny up the optical
information mixed stitched with a little
bit of CGI.
Yeah,
that's great.
Let's see that.
Look,
it looks like a person,
a real person.
That's the sort of person looks like.
I mean your face does look a little
uncanny valley,
but a video game character,
there are about five years away from
that.
Not existing anymore.
Right?
Five years away from just freaking the
fuck out with it.
Like avatar did a great job.
Yeah.
That CGI was like,
I mean,
half of it was the actor's face.
Right?
But the rest of it,
I mean it looked very natural.
What's really cool is that they
immediately for a movie like avatars
that they can have something that's not
a real thing.
Like what's really challenging?
Oh yeah.
Do a CGI of a real thing.
Absolutely.
Or game of thrones do with wolves and
they have to be real careful about.
They shoot it like I am legend with will
Smith.
They did it with lions and it was kind
of clunky.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No that no zombies and I am legend.
That worked perfect because they this
thing a real thing.
Yeah.
It's just like A.
Yeah,
it's a fantasy creature.
You don't have a point of reference.
What is this James
from Logan that digitally did his face
and like almost all of these action
scenes because I don't know whether he
didn't do it or not,
but a little piece just came out.
I don't know if it just came out this
week.
I just saw it the other day.
It's a really cool little three minute
piece about the digital doubles where
it's called of Logan.
Somebody wants to watch that.
I try to put up.
Was that the stunt guy?
Yeah,
this is the stunt guy and then they kind
of show the break though that that was
the actual clip and they'll show you the
breakdown now of how they like added.
Wow.
Each little piece to it to make what you
saw from the little camera angles and
then lead shield.
This is incredible.
It's really cool.
Oh,
that's so the dude just got a God this
and then this thing later here in a
second and show you how all the cameras
that they use to get his actual face.
So this was CGI.
What?
That scene,
that whole scene.
These scenes where CGI.
That's incredible.
Well,
you know what's fucked up?
Even though it's CGI,
they still made it as obvious as a real
fight scene with actors and stuntmen
doesn't movement is real,
but it looks very obvious that it's
fake,
is what I'm saying.
Oh,
now it does.
Yeah.
To me,
but in the movie,
I didn't know.
That's not what I mean.
I mean,
it looks very obvious that it's a fake
fight,
meaning,
oh,
it looks great.
Yeah.
Because you can't actually have a guy
punched the guy.
You can't actually have the guy shoot
him first,
you know,
and he absorbs the bullet and keeps
going and cuts the guy's head off with
his,
with his claws.
But they could have done something along
those lines.
They,
they choreographed it like they would
choreograph like a fight scene and a
$6,000,000
man episode.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
Oh,
I'm gonna Punch you.
you stabbed me first,
I'm going to shoot you long.
You Cut.
Right,
right,
right.
Well,
that's my thing with,
with a tactical scenes and fight scenes.
For me,
it's like it,
it can be.
You just have to balance the
believability level.
So if it's kind of cartoony acts like
violence or whatever,
then make sure that the physics flow
together really
well.
Like captain America winter soldier,
one of my favorite,
uh,
of the marvel movies,
just the fight scenes are incredible.
They really,
really well done and pretty bad ass.
Pretty bad.
Like when fucking winter soldier gets
hit and he likes slides backwards,
you know,
there's always that thing where a guy
gets hit and he slides backwards and
pavement gets torn up and he's like
holding a stance.
But the physics on it looked really
good.
I was like,
oh,
that's great.
And they were just paying attention to
all these little subtle physics details
and that's what makes me appreciate the
fighting or like seeing Gina Carano a
fight like fake fight in movies.
She knows how to take a hit,
right.
So,
so when she gets hit,
she knows what it looks like when you
get hit,
right,
but certain way or certain angle or
whatever.
And not saying that she's the best best,
but just as an example of someone who
actually does make contact or has had
experience in that the reactions are a
little bit more believable and also
they're probably more willing to let
people get close closer I'm sure.
And also you don't feel like you're
being treated like a fool.
Exactly.
That's what I'm,
that's what I'm talking about because
it's otherwise it's just like let you
see the people waiting for the next hit.
Like when you see this,
those fight scenes were people standing
around in a circle and one guy goes in
and then everyone else is waiting.
That would not work like that,
man.
No,
no.
Everybody's just going to wait.
Well that's the rules.
It's just one guy at a time.
Okay.
Now the next.
Okay,
now you try it,
Tony.
Oh God.
He's really good.
Okay.
Walter?
Yeah.
It has to be some like that's one of the
things that I've found almost yearly
impressive about John Wick.
John Wick is preposterous.
See,
that's what I'm saying.
They balanced that shit so when you get
it out because you see it as
choreography,
but it's so fucking tactically and
imaginatively thought out and
stylistically gorgeous and all the,
all the ingredients go together and you
see those,
that footage of him,
you know,
running three gun training or these
fucking rock and through those courses
for real because he's using live rounds
and,
and so when I see that movie,
I'm like,
Oh shit,
these guys know what the fuck they're
doing.
They're not fucking around.
They're like using special forces guys
for training.
They're using a specialized team of
martial artists to create a customized
version of martial arts.
Just for him.
My friend,
he and Machado did a lot of the Jujitsu
choreographed choreography for it.
That's who I was watching.
Yeah.
And I love their whole fucking take on
it and their approach.
It's artistry.
It's like that's what it is.
There was no,
like everything that he did woodwork,
there was no jump up and kick two dudes
in the head at the same time and shoot
through a window and shoot a guy a mile
away and the head no,
no,
no.
It's like if you trained really well and
that situation presented itself the way
that it did,
you could do that.
It's possible.
And,
but it was also very cartoony to
totally.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's what that was so great about it.
So it's like,
it's this perfect because the whole
world was heightened,
you know,
like the whole hotel thing and assassins
having like great grants and the courts.
So it's already in that world.
So you just need to create efficiency,
you know,
all in all it is,
is just like lethal efficiency with a,
with a kiss of artistry.
And there's a uniformity and John Wick's
personality.
Yes.
So,
so Samurai that you believe that he
could do all this and not be affected by
killing all these people.
Yeah,
I know,
I know what it's like.
Other people,
he's killing our.
Our our players.
Yeah.
They're all players in the game and they
deserve it.
They killed his dog.
It killed his dog and anybody who gets
in the way,
not that it's their fault,
but if they decide to take him on then
he just has to.
It's just professional.
He's a professional.
Even in his revenge,
she's perfect.
Well,
except for the part where it shoots the
dude in the hotel and gets
excommunicated,
but other than that,
I mean I just love that character so
much.
I love the stunt driving and that's not
CGI.
That's him.
That's as a 51 year old man fucking
destroying it and I'm like,
you know what,
if anything,
even if you like that type of stuff or
if you don't like that stuff,
just watch a scene.
Look at the artistry of the
choreography.
Think about how old he is now,
hardy,
train,
and then try to have someone who's
sitting on the couch going,
I can't lose.
I can't lose that 30 pounds without.
I mean I'm talking about someone who has
no help.
It's just them alone,
just going,
I can't.
It's like,
man,
it anything is possible.
Any anything is possible.
You just have to fucking do that shit.
Yeah.
Well,
I think that movie is like,
it's a masterpiece of that genre.
There's a lot of those style movies are
fun and everything like that.
Well,
I think what John Wick movies did is
they took that.
They boiled down the story too,
like there's no.
There's no ambiguity as to whether or
not there's bad people and good people.
Whether or not I should kill all these
fucking goofball.
Absolutely.
Should kill them all.
He's absolutely going to.
It's awesome.
Yeah,
and it's okay because it's a game.
Yeah.
That's,
that's the whole thing about it.
That's what's so brilliant about it.
It's like it's a game,
but it allows stunt men tactical expert
forward moviemaking because it's really,
that's what it is.
It's mostly that the stair,
the story kind of takes you along and an
interesting,
but it's a pretty narrow pathway.
The rest,
like the apocalypse now of like shoot
'em off of tactical thrillers or
tactical,
whatever you call them,
whatever you would call those.
The masterpiece of those,
you know,
if you get a chance,
check out this guy.
Have you ever seen strike back?
No.
That's a cinemax show.
Um,
to show.
Yeah.
It's a serious.
Cinemax was real anymore.
Too many networks.
I know skinemax people started.
I remember that back in the day.
Softcore porn and be like,
holy shit,
this is crazy.
They would lie down on the bed and the
lady's leg and naked Lakewood drape
around the man's body.
So you knew what was going on.
I can't believe this.
I know.
Isn't the physics would trick you up?
Be like,
okay.
The way they're lying,
his dick doesn't feel it doesn't look
right.
How is he having sex with her?
Having sex with the front of her vagina?
No Way.
He's reaching
her actual vagina is way too low.
What is he doing?
You know,
the man was.
He was in the wrong spot.
That's so great.
Oh,
she's like,
you're doing it wrong.
Just like,
how does that sit?
Oh,
that's great.
Yeah.
Like just obviously someone in a studio
adding sound later.
Genres about those,
there a series of moves.
Emmanuelle.
Do you remember those?
Emmanuel goes to Paris and Mary
Emmanuelle goes to Italy.
They were all like Danielle steel point?
No,
because Danielle steel,
like it would be more for the ladies.
Oh,
right.
I got you.
Yep.
Right.
Like she was like this,
a exotic traveling lady would fuck these
dudes in hotels in these movies.
So that was so corny.
Oh,
that's right.
But you will be so excited.
But it was softcore.
Yeah.
When I was like 16 when we first got
cable,
you know,
like,
um,
my parents were sleep originally put
there.
Okay.
Cut It.
Tune into showtime or cinemax unless
she's a manual for manual three.
Shit.
Holy Shit.
Everybody was a little kid.
He like,
yeah,
I'm going to see some tiddy.
Oh,
I can't believe I'm going to see a lady
and some more shit.
Yeah.
You're like,
I'm about to see some real adult stuff.
We'll see this lady.
As long as you don't see genitals,
we do not tolerate genitals for breasts
are okay.
But that's not A.
Yeah.
One.
And just walk around in public like Ari
Shaffir does.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
Like,
like,
who's already fear?
The Irish beer stand up.
Comedian.
Good friend of mine thinks he's more
famous than he is obviously a
disadvantage.
Well,
the Cobra Hot Emmanuelle Oh she's.
She's getting acupuncture to be more
hot.
Oh Jesus.
Really?
Undeniable.
Like that 80 is beauty.
Yeah.
Look at that.
God,
I love that guy.
Your ads,
but know.
Fuck the pool guy.
Please fuck the pool guy.
Why don't you have a Cobra and lower
left corner?
Because it's probably someone's like
channel can repost.
Dude.
I remember looking out the window.
Maybe this deck in that building.
That's so crazy.
Maybe I should go to that building.
This building is tired.
She's.
Look,
she's like pretending to be a geisha
cultural appropriation.
Yeah,
totally.
No,
no,
no.
That is.
That is so much reforming.
A ritualistic dance of some sort.
You're that guy.
I had to like try to figure out what was
going on there that she's mounting him
mounted.
Galen Kissing his face.
Just crazy.
Oh,
see,
see other houses.
I go,
yeah.
There was a brief moment.
Look,
nowhere near each other is.
Yeah.
It's just like the idea.
It's like theater,
sex.
It was the beginnings of like figuring
out the loophole between pornography and
then romantic movies with essentially no
plot.
They could write the not like,
oh,
we're just going to get to.
We'll figure it out when
we get there.
Uh,
this is what I want you to do.
Look out the window.
Where's Bob fucking bar kit over here?
I'm horny.
I'm Bob.
Bob Shows up in a yacht and that story
to make it look like,
oh,
is this a TV show?
Because it's a TV shop.
Gets off the boat.
I can't believe you're here.
I didn't know you were coming.
Yes,
let's go get a drink.
And then they go into the next room.
Next thing is still,
they start making out.
I missed you so much.
I miss you too.
Have made some mistakes.
I'm so sorry.
Next thing you know,
it's like,
I can't do this.
It's like,
well,
why not?
Just one night.
It's just one night.
All right.
Yeah,
they smoke cigarettes in bed together
back then.
Everybody smoked.
I never really got the cigarette.
Cigarette after six post fuck thing.
People like to smoke.
Yeah.
You don't get it because you don't like,
I don't like to smoke.
No,
never smoked.
No.
Good for you.
My parents did stupid hobby.
I know.
It's a tough one,
man.
Yeah,
I get it.
My mom quit cold Turkey Turkey though.
Thirteen years ago.
Good for her.
She's 80 now.
Jesus.
She.
Okay.
Yeah.
How long have you smoked for?
She smoked like probably sensor like
late teens.
See,
that's what every long term smoker.
They hear that story.
They go along as I just know when to
jump off this ride.
I'm going to be okay.
Remember those bugs bunny movies were
playing.
Was about to crash right before the
plane hit the ground bugs bunny would
just hop off.
Yes.
And it plane would crash and you'd be
like,
fine.
I love that.
That's what it is.
That's what your mom did was like,
fuck,
I'm okay.
Yeah,
I'm done.
Well that was fun.
That was it.
I mean,
no one people die of cancer.
Like from lung cancer,
like weight quicker than that.
Oh yeah.
My Dad.
That's when my dad died from.
Boy,
he,
he had heart trouble first and then he
had um,
like a bunch of heart surgeries because
he was like,
had like a high salt,
he wasn't overweight,
he was thin,
so it's like one of those thin fat type
of patients.
So he's have just a genetic issue.
I don't know what it was,
it was just like some kind of like build
up because he was a smoker,
is a heavy smoker.
He ate kind of heavy food,
salty,
whatever and um,
and it just added up and then he got,
he got heart problems than emphysema,
emphysema turned to lung cancer.
And then my mom,
like last year she,
she discovered she only had like 18
percent functionality or no,
like 13 percent functionality of her
heart and I just happened to be in
Montana at the time because I don't have
brothers and sisters and I just happened
to be there with a friend of mine for
Christmas and it happened the day after
Christmas.
So she was like,
I really don't feel well today to the
hospital.
They're like,
yeah,
you've got barely any coronary
functionality right now.
And so then they put in to a two stents,
but a third of her heart is not
functioning.
One of the aorta just doesn't work
anymore.
Pretty,
pretty heavy.
But a lot of it is from just like high
fat,
high set a high salt.
I'm smoking.
Yeah.
You know,
the thing is people used to think it was
high fat.
Did you read that thing in the New York
Times about where
that all came from?
The reason why people think saturated
fat is bad for you yet.
Well,
I know that certain amounts of fats and
certain fats are awesome for you on
summer.
It all came from the New York Times.
I mean,
it all came from the sugar industry.
The sugar industry bribed all these
scientists and they didn't even have to
pay him much.
Man.
Apparently it was only like $50,000.
They bribed these scientists to study,
uh,
to report some bogus findings,
pushing the blame away from sugar and
onto saturated fat.
Oh,
history.
Yeah.
To this day,
people think saturated fat is bad for
you.
There's something that I tweeted earlier
today that I was reading about
saturated,
being able to even cholesterol.
Cholesterol is the precursor.
It's like what you need.
It's a substrate for hormones.
Sure,
sure.
No,
absolutely,
but just saying like,
there's so much of it.
There's so much.
Dietary cholesterol is not even a man.
Dire.
Taylor,
Terry cholesterol apparently doesn't
even move your blood lipids.
A lot of it's genetic.
It has to do with whether or not you
have high cholesterol has to do with
your lifestyle.
If you're a sedentary,
yeah,
sure.
A lot of sugar and carbs.
This is something that I posted earlier
today.
Fat when fat people or rather when
people eat saturated fat,
the risk of stroke drops.
If they're also avoiding refined
carbohydrates,
their triglycerides also come down,
so what they're saying is that when
people eat saturated fat in conjunction
with eating a lot of refined
carbohydrates like white flour and
sugar,
it's not good for you at all.
So the that that saturated fat is bad is
the wrong culprit.
Like saturated fat might be bad for you
if you had refined carbohydrates because
you like.
You're just fucking your whole system
up,
but if you can remove the refined
carbohydrates,
saturated fat consumers have a lower
risk of stroke and their triglycerides
come down to the.
You actually get healthier by eating
saturated fat without carbohydrates.
That's totally makes sense.
It does make sense,
but this is all new shit,
man.
These separated it that they.
It looks like they just kind of finally
went like it's kind of true.
It's only true in combination.
It's only true in combination,
but you extract the one that we know to
be bad because there's many,
many studies right now showing that low
carbohydrate diets are beneficial for a
bunch of different total health
benefits.
So when you take out these refined
carbohydrates,
it turns out the saturated fat is good
for you.
Haven't been.
We've known them for awhile.
I mean carbs.
Refined carbs are not good.
I mean,
I look at it,
but we didn't know how bad they were.
Oh yeah.
I think we're realizing now more how bad
they are and how important saturated fat
and unsaturated fats are and there's a
lot of saturated fats even for plant
based folks.
You get a certain percentage of it from
Avocados,
I think you can get a little bit of it
from coconut oil,
certain percentage of it from coconut
oil.
I think it's they're saying coconut.
That's bullshit.
A little bit of a thing was widely
criticized by signing.
That was the hardest association wrote
that and they.
These all these scientists got together
in on.
It
actually published an article about it
where we sent essentially the American
heart association is kind of whack.
Like their research is kind of Shitty,
like too bad there are behind the times
as it makes sense.
You have to be the cutting edge
nutrition.
This is why it's so confusing.
It's constantly revolving around the
latest science,
so if you're not using the latest
science cutting edge new,
you're not using the latest cutting edge
in nutrition.
So if you're talking about some shit
that they discovered the 19 seventies,
there's a bit of possibility that you
might be wrong is tainted.
Yeah,
I mean that totally makes sense.
I mean that's something that I tend to
fail.
You know,
my thing is like I just try to eat like
what would a diabetic do,
like that's a good,
that's a good starting place.
And then the other thing is just like
simplicity,
you know,
like uh,
for me,
chicken breast,
lean fish,
snapper,
brown rice,
oatmeal,
steam,
Broccoli,
steamed Kale,
I'm egg whites,
egg white protein.
But even egg whites,
egg whites are not nearly as healthy for
you.
Is Egg yolks?
Yolks are actually better for you.
It yolks have more protein in them
there.
There's a,
there's all sorts of vitamins that you
get an egg,
you don't care about the powder,
you know,
like the more protein,
but a good percentage of the protein I
should say.
And more cholesterol.
The cholesterol is really the thing for
me.
Like Jay,
you know Jay Robb,
egg,
white protein,
that stuff is so fucking crack.
It's great and it mixes really well if
they think they could put the yolk in
there.
I don't ever use plant based protein,
like pea protein is really good.
Pump protein if you have from a good
source.
Yeah,
I've used all of those things.
I guess egg white is like the most
easily one of the most easily absorbed,
so,
um,
and it's just kind of simple.
What I like about is that it's simple
and it just comes from an unrefined ish,
you know,
refined to get it to a powder.
Right.
But that's what I would say the issue is
in the dehydration,
dehydration process.
It's so different than with hamp where
you're essentially just getting the
plant fiber grind to get down to a fine
powder and then you eat it.
So it's super easy to digest.
It's almost like,
like squeezed juice except for it's a
dried plant versus a dehydrated liquid
product to kind of liquidy,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Kind of.
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
I guess,
I guess they are,
they start that way,
but if you cook them or.
I mean,
I guess you could have them raw.
Well you can,
if you've got,
you know,
the source apparently catching
salmonella though from backyard
chickens.
Oh yeah,
that's a,
that is an issue now there's some far.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Right.
And there was that huge movement.
I'm like urban movement,
so people who are closer together,
be careful.
If you don't,
you know,
know what's going on.
Don't,
don't eat it raw.
Just because you've got it in your
backyard does not necessarily mean it's
100 percent safety role.
Yeah.
No,
I,
you know,
my thing is like,
I just need some pretty simply.
Do you eat fish?
Yeah.
What kind of fatty fish?
Like salmon supposed to be the best for
you?
I do like salmon.
I like Coho Salmon,
which is really good if you can.
And then um,
I like Hamachi how much he is just a
amazing macro.
I really dig mackerels great snappers
really nice for like just like a nice
lean piece of fish.
Like next one.
That basic.
Do you ever go fishing?
I know you used to in Montana and grew
up in Montana.
I used to fish a.
no,
not fly fish,
just like boat fish,
fish,
Montana.
Where were?
Yeah,
like lake a lake?
Yeah.
I forget the.
Forget that.
Oh,
we went to a rainbow lake.
I think rainbow,
like flat head sometimes.
We went to Bozeman last summer,
my family,
and we went whitewater rafting down in
Gallatin.
It's amazing,
dude.
You get soaked though.
If you're in the shade,
you're going to freeze your dick off.
That was glacial runoff.
The only one of the few times I noticed
between a shadow and not shadow.
Yeah.
If you're in the sun,
you're like,
Aha,
it's perfect.
I'll dry off.
I'll be fine,
but if you're in the cold in the water
is cold,
man.
You're so fucked and you're just like,
take one step into the sunlight and
you're like,
it's like breathing.
That Galton's weird because there's a
lot of people that fly fish in that
gallatin river,
but almost everybody releases the fish
that they catch.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I got you.
Yeah.
It's more like the sportsman.
Yeah,
take on it.
Rather than just you just tricking this
fish sticking out,
hook in his head and then you're pulling
it to shore and then let it go.
Letting it go.
Like how many times,
if this is like a stream or a lot of
people on this river,
if a lot of people fly fish,
what are the odds that a fish gets
caught and released?
Like several times and it's life man.
That'd be something to ask.
Like you're getting a hook Jesus again
or maybe like,
you know what?
I don't mind it because I'm still alive.
I don't know.
I think it would suck.
Yeah,
don't think that they have nerve
endings.
The in their mouth the way I think it's
like the,
a lot of the tissue in their mouth other
than their throat is like,
I'm almost like a fingernail.
I think it's the way I see.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
I mean because that was the thing.
It's like I,
I love fish but I'm a little bit of a
pussy about killing,
you know?
And so I have to Kinda like get into a
mindset,
you know,
to do it.
I mean I could,
I could do it if I needed to survive.
I need to cut.
Of course I'm going to eat.
I don't have a problem with that.
What about an ugly fish?
Like a flounder?
It doesn't matter.
I was the kid trying to not step on
ants.
Right.
That was,
I was just like very much.
Even though I do eat meat,
although I will say I'm really stoked
about Memphis meats.
Memphis meats.
Yeah.
They're out of San Francisco.
They're growing steaks and chicken.
Now,
is that actual steak and actual chicken
or is it a Vegan alternative from the
cells?
The animals.
You're going to get a Zombie idea.
So yeah,
I mean something.
So it was good but,
but,
but I do think that it's an interesting
thing because like,
I was Vegan for like seven years and now
I'm not.
Do you get people mad at you because of
the,
you know,
I've gotten some people like I thought
you were.
I thought you were a vegetarian or
Vegan.
Are you open minded?
Man?
I thought you could.
But the thing is like I do care and I am
pretty particular about the sources of
protein.
I'm very particular,
but uh,
but I am excited about this idea of
because it,
it,
it poses an interesting question to
someone who's choosing to be Vegan for
ethical reasons or health reasons or
both.
Um,
if meat was able to be grown,
like saying that you liked me before you
became one you liked.
I liked it,
but I don't like the ethical reasons.
Make sense for health reasons.
Totally.
I would feel like,
you know,
it's probably just as bad for you or
worse unless,
unless you feel.
Unless you feel bad when you eat certain
things.
Not like emotionally,
but if you have a reaction to me,
some people do have,
that was fine.
The people to do,
you know,
that's a real common thing recently
about that lone star tick disease.
No.
People getting allergic to meat.
There's some,
some weird.
Yeah.
Something that is in the bite of the
tick,
uh,
something called,
they call it Alpha Gal for short.
And when you get this,
you develop this allergy to this stuff
that exists in red meat.
And so when people get bitten by this
one particular tick,
they literally develop an allergy to red
meat and it can subside over time.
But for a lot of people they have to.
They stick to chicken and fish
afterwards.
They literally become allergic to eat
meat,
so they become healthier.
But I don't necessarily see that's where
the.
That's where the whole saturated fat
argument comes into shirt.
I guess it depends on the Diet is
there's all this confusion about whether
or not red meat is bad for you.
Because a lot of these studies that show
that there's a direct correlation
between red meat and heart attacks.
What they don't do is differentiate what
kind of red meat.
They don't make a differentiation
between red meat that's grass fed,
pasture raised cattle.
It's very healthy or bison versus a fast
food burger with a white bread,
buns and French fries and a soda with
all sorts of sugar in it.
See,
because you.
Because the fact that people eat red
meat on a daily basis,
they don't take into consideration what
they eat that red meat with.
And there's a giant difference between
eating a piece of grass fed meat with
vegetables and water,
you know,
maybe a Yam versus eating a fucking
Carl's junior double cheeseburger with
fake bacon just dripping with funk and
sugary,
sugary sauces.
Yeah,
I mean you,
you can't make the people do.
And so the correlation between like,
it's not a good.
These are not good tests because the
correlation between red meat and cancer,
you could say maybe,
maybe,
but not the way you guys showed it,
the way you guys showed it as just
eating red meat with a bunch of other
shit versus eating red meat and living a
healthy life.
Yeah.
And eating with vegetables and having a
what you would call a balanced diet.
Yep.
You can't say that it's all the same
because it's just not great.
I,
no,
I totally agree with that.
I mean for me the red meat is like,
I'll just feel better if I'm not eating
it all the time and I just prefer
chicken or whatever to to a lot of
people have different.
They have different reactions to all
kinds of things.
I know several people that have celiacs
where they literally can't consume any
bread.
I know a bunch of people that have that
and for those people,
everybody's obviously different than
mine because mine,
if I eat bread,
I don't feel as good feed a big ass sub
sub.
It feels great while it's going down for
an afternoon crash.
Sometimes it's,
it's hard to remember that because
you're like,
well I just want the thing,
the difference between A.
I'm an in and out double double with a
button versus protein style with the
lettuce.
Yeah,
it's a different thing.
I completely agree.
I mean I'm,
you know,
for me it's like,
like,
you know,
feeling menial or something like that.
It's like really nice because it's like
a very lean cut,
but blue cheese on the.
I don't know about.
I don't know if I can go there.
I like,
I like the blue cheese for laymen.
Y'All,
you know Jamie's to white bread from
Ohio.
They don't even know what blue cheeses
over there turn into a cheeseburger.
Just leave.
They have no blue cheese with a little
crumbled blue cheese with some fucking
look at you.
I'll tell you.
Here's the problem.
Honestly.
It also like Philemon,
Yana is a boring cut,
like a rib eyes.
The cut just like cooked in there and
you get a fucking nice dark surface on
the outside and yet slice and it's red
in the middle and get a hunk of fat in
your mouth.
So much better tasting than Philemon
neon.
So I will not have blue cheese with a
ribeye.
I,
I will,
I will say that,
uh,
at Pacific dining car and what they do,
but they make the most perfect related
mean,
you know,
there's like nothing on it.
It's just just the steak.
But it is like the most flavor complex
piece of meat to the downtown one or the
one that's downtown one.
See the downtown one is like 24 hours a
day,
isn't it?
Yeah.
How is that possible?
So I get a steak at Pacific dining car
downtown la at 4:00
in the morning.
You could,
I need to go?
Yeah.
We need to have like a post show,
Pacific dining car dinner.
Yeah.
These days.
Yeah,
for sure as to the store because we're
always going to these bullshit places to
eat.
Yeah.
That place,
that place rocks and I just.
It's got that heritage server vibe to
it.
It's really cool.
I dig that man.
Have you gone to the one in Santa
Monica?
I have not,
no.
Excellent.
Is it?
They're both.
Excellent.
Okay.
I'll take super old school steakhouse.
Yeah.
There's something about that that like
when they have a relationship with the,
with the,
with the cattle farm or whatever,
but I will say I am excited about a
grown steak.
Right.
Are you excited about something when
something doesn't have to die ethically,
completely safe.
Clipping taste.
If it tastes as good as the original and
you're just like,
no,
I love,
I love both of these.
Then you would obviously I would choose
the one that was just 100 percent.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Just because like,
well,
just an efficiency.
I mean,
you know,
get rid of the empathy,
the emotional thing,
but like even just for efficiency's
sake,
like about this,
the saving the environment from methane,
methane that.
Totally.
The problem is we don't need cows
anymore.
We'll have to start marking those cows.
I know I fucked and just grow.
They're going to be like,
dear.
Oh yeah,
dude online,
true.
I'm a photo from his house in Long
Island and he was saying that long
island is just infested with deer and
that they literally going in and giving,
giving these,
these deer operations and they're,
they're,
yeah,
they're trying to remove their ovaries.
They're giving them birth control pills
and trying all these different ways.
Oh my goodness.
All these different proposals.
And even some places they hired snipers.
They're giving.
They're trying to figure out what to do
because there's no predators and there's
just a fucking astounding number of
deer.
But that's,
you know,
it's,
it goes.
It's just human civilization.
Like we just,
it's a domino effect.
We keep like fucking sort of.
But the real issue is just no predators.
I mean,
if they really want to hold,
if they released a bunch of wolves,
sure they take care of that.
I agree with.
That was a human decision,
you know what I'm saying that because
those ecosystems work perfectly and then
we'd come in and we're like,
I don't like those trees over there and
a bird goes away and then like,
that bird was responsible for this thing
and that blah blah blah blah blah.
And then I don't like wolves eat my
kids.
I hate wolves.
I don't like the way they have sharp
teeth out like it one bit and they don't
look very,
very friendly.
So.
So whatever the reason.
But.
So that's kind of what you get.
Yeah.
Really,
monkey with a perfect system.
Yeah.
But once you monkey with that perfect
system,
once you monkeyed it out,
yeah,
you're responsible.
You just fucking deer everywhere.
Yeah.
You got to keep your lending.
I know you got to keep it running,
man.
For people live around there.
It's a huge pain in the ass because they
crashed into those things all the time
now and you could die.
I've had friends at run into meese and a
moose.
Moose is run into a tree.
It's like,
it's like a tech stories of like some
guy who had a pickup truck was going
like,
oh no,
45,
something like that.
Fifty hit a hit.
A Moose and the most just walked into
the forest.
Probably broke a lot of shit,
but that shit,
but it walked away.
It'll probably,
hopefully he'll see the video on
youtube.
Very recently of a guy hitting a moose
on the highway in Canada and it launches
it into the air.
I mean launches it like the Musha steps
out into the road and I'm boom,
this guy hits it with his car and the
people that are filming,
it'll like,
oh shit,
just flying through the air.
Got fucking flying like 20,
30 feet through the air.
What happened to it?
That I don't know.
It's just a video that is.
It might not have man.
I mean,
it might have been.
They're so tough.
They're just,
here it is right here.
Me Sir.
Tough.
This guy's driving.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
That's not alive.
That looks like a deer more than most.
The other one that I saw honestly,
Jamie was different.
Maybe it's the same video from a
different angle.
That's almost.
Oh my God.
That's incredible.
That's dead.
He's just lying.
He gets scared and he's playing dead
because he doesn't want anybody up.
That was definitely dead.
Uh,
definitely dead.
And that car is Jack my five.
That's probably totaled a caved in bent
frame.
That's just suck so bad.
Well,
they,
you know,
it's some place like in Idaho,
Montana where they have those
underpasses are those overpasses,
which is pretty great to help the
animals nature.
I always,
I think that's so,
I mean there's like so many things we
could do.
Obviously it's resource intensive and
whether people agree with it or not,
but we could totally be in harmony with
things for guns.
You don't have time for that.
You're right.
You're doing that on our,
our Tuesday a project to do that on the
one on one for mountain lions.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They should do.
Apparently the genetic diversity of the
mountain lions is threatened by the one
on one because there's mountain lions on
the ocean side and they're like breeding
too much with the mountain lions over
there,
too hard for them to get across to
[inaudible] to find all the mountain
lions on this side as you go deep into
like I'm Simi Valley and those areas.
So apparently they're trying to figure
out some way to mitigate that and one of
the best ideas is really wide strip of
land so these things feel comfortable
and again to like pave it.
I mean they're gonna like put dirt in
there and yeah,
I've seen those.
They look great too.
It's a shit load of money.
Yeah.
But you know what they need to do that
shit.
I mean it's like,
you know,
if we have enough shit humans already,
like even even some of us,
I mean minus mental problems,
mental issues,
it's like we have so much.
It's just,
it's,
it's crazy.
Even when I was like,
I mean I was never like destitute,
but I was definitely very,
very poor and wasn't sure if I would
make rent or had to borrow a lot of
money for,
for a few years and things like that.
But then you just realize how much you
have.
Like I mean if your risk,
if you're in comparison in comparison,
like I can always find water.
I could always find water and if I was
social enough I could definitely gain
the trust of people to be able to let me
crash for awhile on a,
on a,
on a couch.
So there was always a way to survive
even if there are little things.
So I.
The reason why I bring that up is just
because like nature to kind of our job
to be stewards of,
of nature,
it should be better at it.
It certainly isn't a lot of ways we
certain Julie should be responsible.
That's why it should be so much more of
a big deal when something like some sort
of a company pollutes a bay or a no shit
like that is.
It is such a giant deal,
you can't like gloss over it with a
clean up.
What you've done is like Devin,
like that whole thing that happened with
bp and the oil spill in the Gulf.
Like they devastated an entire
ecosystem.
I mean that all the people that relied
on that area for fishing,
all that and then the people that live
nearby and then the people that had a
clean it apparently the people that had
to clean up their own brain cancer.
No,
no Bueno.
You've got to clean up gasoline.
Spill oil spill all day.
That should be good for you.
Are you breathing that in?
Good.
What do you got over your face?
Like one of them fucking three m,
three m mask and then paper masks that
should be sufficient.
Definitely is going to filter out all
the toxins that are going to get into
your DNA.
So terrible man.
I mean,
you know,
as much of deep water horizon oil spill
is disappeared because of bacteria.
Oh that's good.
Well they were eating microbes,
didn't they?
Didn't they?
They poured that on there,
didn't.
They was like one of the thing that's
some new shit they're going to use
actually for plastic as well.
Chemicals used to disperse it to kept
underwater.
Making it more available to the microbes
that live in the deeper portions,
the ocean.
What's up with all those facebook things
like right in front of it.
It just like an issue with the a website
called Shitty shitty coding.
CNBC.
Fox.
You've seen them.
We see.
That's amazing.
I just love when someone super smart
figures out a giant issues we have with
something simple.
Yeah.
No microbes.
Microbes can make oil or fungus.
Fungus.
Fungus is great.
Fungus gets rid of oil,
but meanwhile those microbes are going
to get eaten by fish and those fish are
going to become huge and they're going
to start thinking through and they go,
I'm tired of these motherfuckers coming
in and killing us.
We got to go out there and kill them.
I hope so.
I don't.
I mean if they tried to really fuck with
us,
that'd be good.
If there's like a new blue,
go to war with the fish and feel good
about eating them.
Maybe.
What does this bacteria are evolving to
eat?
Plastic we dump into the ocean.
Whoa.
Through evolving to do it without us
doing it.
That's not good.
We're going to make an alien man like
the movie alien.
Like the guard Geiger Alien.
Yeah.
You mean the xenomorph more?
Do you see,
um,
I posted this thing on instagram a
couple of days ago that I saw from
nature is metal,
the instagram account,
and it's a cuddle fish.
Have you ever seen how cuddle fish
Jack's other fish?
No.
Spirit watch this.
It doesn't even seem real.
Look at that.
It's like an underwater frog,
but the way it opens up like a flower
and put this thing into it.
I mean this is incredible at it.
Stabs it and then it's so cool.
It's such a great system because it's
like,
it keeps it close to stay in camouflage.
Yeah.
And then it only opens it last second
and probably maybe the color.
Mesmer as the CND and enemies.
It literally takes on the shape and
texture of the sea and enemies.
That's amazing.
The,
the amount of camouflaged it has this
insane.
There's somehow or another,
I guess related to octopus,
we can,
which many of the activists can do the
same thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The change gear.
The camouflage thing is insane.
I mean nature is like way more advanced
than we'll ever that.
I mean what we are in nature,
but um,
but it's just like from our point of
view,
looking at nature,
which is just like an evolution of its
molecular.
Meanwhile the octopus is like,
what the fuck are you complaining about?
Dude?
You have a phone.
Okay.
You can fly on a plane.
You're pitching that you can't turn into
like you look like a coral reef.
Nobody gives a fuck.
Is that a cuddle fish right there
pretending to be a coral reef.
So mine isn't crab crab.
What are they feeding?
A crab grass.
Oh whoa.
Look at that fucker.
That's amazing.
What a weird look and freaky alien
creature and I love it's propulsion
system is great.
Just undulates signed.
It's so cool.
It's just.
I love it.
I love the.
I also really love spiders.
Spiders or just to king of camouflage
played that video,
that king of camouflage the cuttlefish
and cuddly looking.
They do have like a little smile to them
in these cute guys.
They mean the same kind of cuddle.
I think it's cuddle with a Ct.
No,
no.
That's what they meaNt.
What they meant.
Look at how it just becomes like
whatever it's near.
Like when it sits down on stuff yet it's
so complicated.
It looks like other fish.
Oh,
that's a octopus.
Yeah.
Like look at this octopus as it's on the
ground in cephalopod.
These things are just.
They've adapted so cool.
A way to fake it just,
it just so alien to us.
And that's the thing about like,
oh my god,
look crazy.
Look at how it looks like the bottom of
that thing that it's in.
It looks more like I'm cooler than
octopus face.
You knoW,
like you were talking about before about
the idea of aliens visiting us.
Like why would we think that they would
look like us at all?
Oh yeah.
No,
I mean to,
you know,
they could just be spheres of energy
period and they're just like,
hey guys,
what's up?
Why do they have to have a language even
convey intent?
Well,
that's why I liked,
uh,
what was that movie that came out
recently?
The alien.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The one up with the one that memory one,
which I wrote off at first.
Then I went back and watched it and
that's pretty fucking what's it caLled
again?
Because I didn't like it.
I don't remember jeremy renner.
That guy stepped upon arrival.
Arrival.
Yeah.
I really liked that.
I liked it.
Eventually,
first sought when the girl died.
I was like,
get the fuck out of here.
You're not going to get me with this.
I know,
I know.
Yeah.
And then like,
man,
that changed real quick.
Yeah,
it was very interesting.
It was like,
and they were something totally
different,
you know?
Yes.
The way I feel,
it's like,
why would we assume that everything
would be physical when we have things
like wifi,
we have like literally all of the
world's data coming to you on your phone
from space with zero connection.
You take that thing,
spin that phone around,
there's nothing physical connecting it.
So why wouldn't we assume that
information travels from alien,
the alien like that?
Why do they,
why do they need a language?
Do they need,
why do they need to be able to touch
things and see things and feel things?
Yeah,
agree.
It might be information that might be an
alien.
That's why,
you know,
like when people talk about doing dmt or
or uh,
or even ketamine know,
like that kind of dissociative
intelligences that people are
intelligence has been lobbying on
dissociated.
It was like that.
They feel around them like almost an
insight and like intelligence.
That's what I think.
Like everything is just pure content.
It's just everything is consciousness
around you all the time,
all the time.
It's entirely possible.
I mean,
you know,
it's like that's what you are.
So all we are is.
I mean,
as far as we know are vibrating weird
particles,
we just don't have the senses to deal
with whatever the fuck else is around.
We have to deal with all our biological
needs,
all of our imperatives,
what we need to concentrate on in order
to stay functional as a flesh bag.
We're at division of consciousness.
We're literally lifeforms.
We are forms of life.
Well,
your body literally is an avatar for
consciousness.
Oh yeah.
Movie.
That's what I call the biomechanical
consciousness transport system.
That's a good name for it.
You want to talk to chicks?
I'm going to do is we're just going to
get in the hot tub with our biological
transport,
so containment vehicles whenever,
whenever something deal to hot tub.
It feels good.
Yeah.
You know,
constantly over here and you sit over
there.
So some,
uh,
some,
some women would take that and be like,
yeah,
that's cool.
And then you're like,
yeah,
yeah.
Girls with tattoos,
like right above their taste.
They wouLd go for that.
They'd be like,
yeah,
I like what you're saying.
if he made me feel good about my choice,
a dig it.
Thanks man.
You want some of this joint,
if you have a hairdo like yours,
man,
you can pull that kind of talk off.
Although that fat jewish guys made that
haircut a little fucked up.
That guy's kinda like tapped into it in
a way.
It's.
Yeah.
Coming to change,
man.
Come and issue a strange man.
The guy guy debord on your shirt who's
guide to board to board.
I don't care anymore.
He started.
Yeah,
fuck this.
It's the guy who started the
situationists.
They were kind of like a philosophical
artistic movement in the fifties in
french.
And they got a basically credit.
it was kind of like data ism mixed with
like some different artists like
artistic techniques and some philosophy,
but they would do these exercises to
kind of shake their orientation like
they love disorientation.
So they would,
uh,
you know,
drink a bunch of absent and walk around
their town light and act like a group of
them would like,
act like they were tourists in their own
town and they would look.
They would navigate by looking up at the
buildings as opposed to a street level.
So they would do things like that or
take maps,
tourist maps of other cities and
superimpose them block for block,
like on another city,
or they did jokes like we are,
we're like kind of bits where one guy
dressed as a bishop and actually lead a
sermon at a.
I'm a notre dam and a
don't ever say that again,
frank.
They were like pranksters.
They were like,
kind of like sticky notes with them
there.
and they were credited.
Malcolm mclaren was a,
It was a situationist and uh,
he created kind of partially created the
sex pistols as living mannequins for his
fashion.
Oh wow.
So the punk movement is kind of
associated with situationist because
they,
their whole mantra.
I mean,
it's a distillation,
but it's like a provoked to the edge of
violence.
Whoa.
No,
that's,
that's interesting.
Was there ever a documentary on these
guys?
There might be.
I've never,
I've never found one was just like,
there's the society of the spectacle,
which is one of the books that he wrote.
And there's like twO,
two books that he,
that he wrote did boards the society of
the spectacle.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Yes,
self will self takes a walk
through the.
How do you say that,
ben?
Ben.
When ben news of patty,
uh,
the been,
I think it's been used and used betty
have belly and is astonished by the
press events.
Is that the right way to say that?
Uh,
yeah.
Press events of a debord 1967
masterpiece,
which so accurately describes the shit
we're in.
Interesting.
Basically a society of the spectacle and
more fucking issues with the twitter
thing showing up right there on the
pictures.
The fuckers with Your browser son has
zoom in and it fucks with it,
which they probably have ad blockers and
all kinds of weird.
Oh,
that's probabLy what it is.
Maybe you've been hacked.
Son had a c,
k,
d.
Anyways,
that's who he is.
You know about that guy?
Yeah.
When I first,
when I first moved to New York,
I,
a friend of mine and a performance
artist took me to this experimental
theater that was in a garage and
williamsburg like way back who was still
pretty shitty city cd.
And you walk into the garage and they
had this theater piece on [inaudible]
board and uh,
it was amazing as soon as it,
because they kind of explained what it
was about and the journey and blah,
blah blah.
But it was also done in a style that
would have been situation.
So we were just like on these boards
that we're on top of buckets for seats
for bleachers.
And then they were passing around like
beers,
like,
so people were just drinking beers and
watching this play.
And it was amazing and it really
inspired me where I was like,
oh yeah,
I dig.
I like it.
I liked that pranking,
hacking,
social hacking.
It's nice.
Provoked to the point of violence,
violence for violence or annoying
neighbor.
Yeah.
Basically.
BuT someone who's doing it on purpose,
which is even more annoying,
super annoying.
More than just like,
oh,
he's an annoying person.
So I don't know,
this person's doing it on purpose.
Like andy kaufman,
situationist.
Yeah.
He wouldn't necessarily maybe have
described himself as that,
but that's,
he's a perfect example of that.
Or andy warhol more kaufman,
right?
Because warhol was just creating art.
Well yeah,
buT his whole like a con artist kind of
vibe whether he would have ascribed to
or not,
but the fact that he was kind of causing
a little bit,
you know,
that handled the campbell soup soup
campaign is a little bit of a con.
It was a little bit,
but people enjoyed looking at it.
They did,
but it started.
It's kind of like when I see it,
I'm like,
ah,
that's a little bit of a con in the
factory idea,
you know,
um,
is also a little bit of a con.
It's a little bit of a,
of a hack.
I mean,
in a conscious,
really intelligent,
philosophical way.
It's not to say that he's really trying
to fool it.
It's not that he's just like this and
people are like,
yes,
I like it.
And he's like,
that's what I thought.
Right,
right.
A little weird when like people push
back against someone trying to push what
they think is too far.
Like I'm like the,
they become these big cultural arguments
as to what's art and what's not.
Especially when things are funded,
like do you remember piss christ?
Do you remember all that?
You don't remember that.
That was,
um,
scott dammit.
What was his name?
I was just starting out doing stand up.
So it was the late eighties.
God,
what is his name?
What was his name?
Okay.
Wasn't that one I was thinking of.
There was a,
that was one.
It was a p,
there was another guy,
there was another guy who was famous for
that kind of shit.
God dammit.
very controversial artist who did a lot
of like weird sexual and odd stuff in
like the late eighties,
early nineties.
And it became a huge issue because
people were mad that it,
some of it was being funded and put up
in museums that were state funded.
oh,
interesting.
Got damaged.
It's at the tip of my tongue.
I can't remember this guy's name,
but these are like pieces of art,
like art works.
Yeah.
And piss christ was one of them.
What piss christ was,
was a,
a jar of pis with a crucifix in it and
it was on display in a museum.
Oh,
I do remember thAt.
Yeah,
people were like,
what in the fuck is this?
And they called it piss christ and
people would travel from all over.
Yeah.
Oh,
the world to go stare at pittsburgh.
It was the audacity,
right?
Part of it is the audacity to just do
something like that and just be like
cool with it.
I mean that's my favorite art is like
one of my favorite moments and kind of
discovering that was when I was going to
quit.
I was going to cornish college of the
arts in seattle and uh,
every,
I think it was every tuesday or thursday
or maybe wednesday,
one of the middle days,
they would allow students to throw a
concert in the theater and the small
poncho hall theater and you could just
sign up for it and you can do whatever
you wanted.
And one day it was like all the kind of,
I guess I would call them performance
art,
the musician,
a conceptual musician,
bad asses,
like all on stage.
And it was like brent arnold on cello,
scott,
even kang,
I'm a on violin or viola and a guy on
base,
just like five or six people onstage,
all badasses.
Tim young and uh,
and I was in the theater and there were
like maybe 23 kids and a 60 seat theater
just like chilling,
scattered throughout the seats.
And they started playing and everybody
was playing through distortion pedals
and they just started playing these
distortion drones like all of them.
And then eventually it just sounded,
it,
you saw people doing things on stage,
but all you could hear was
for like a,
probably an hour and a.
And I had earplugs in and everybody
cleared out,
like everybody cleared out.
And I hung to the end.
But I started like,
I started like head bobbing because as
soon as I started realizing that static,
whether you're seeing visual static or
audio static,
after a while you start to hallucinate
and you start to,
you start to hear music and static.
So if you hear eventually when you
defocus,
it's like those,
you know,
those um,
magic I puzzles where you're supposed to
hold your thumb and then all of sudden,
oh,
I can see this three dimensional image,
same exact concept essentially.
but your mind is creating the structure
that you metric structure because it
wants to find structure and static is
like raw energy.
So of like jodie foster in contact and
she would stare at the static trying to
find patterns in it.
Exactly.
That's exactly right.
Yeah,
yeah.
Similar thing.
And so what.
So I started like,
I just couldn't stop,
like head headbanging essentially,
but it was really slow and then
afterwards they came up to me and
they're like,
oh,
okay,
you're one of those.
Just remember the bass player sayinG
that to me.
And I was like,
oh,
that's so cool.
Like he didn't,
he didn't have to explain anything at
all.
It's like a news thing.
So for me,
when I see duration pieces,
things that test people's patience,
I love it.
I love seeing people.
I can't stand this.
And was just like,
no,
just,
wait,
just hang in there.
No,
it can stay there or it's pissing people
off.
I love it.
It's like there's or not even pissing
them off,
just making them frustrated like there's
a certain amount of frustration that I
think is fun to play with.
At least.
At least when I'm doing comedy.
A little bit of that is,
is good.
Just like little doses here and there is
kind of my thing.
I like it.
It's a good feeling,
but I'm testing to see if people are
willing to relax.
Yeah,
yeah,
totally.
You just like,
I'm just fucking with you.
Just keep that in mind when I'm doing
something that seems kind of frustrating
and if you can keep both those things in
mind,
you can relax and just go for the ride
if you,
if you want or you could just be like,
this fucking sucks and leave,
which is fine.
To me,
it's not for.
It's not for everybody.
Nothing.
Nothing is.
Right.
It's not all dependent upon whether or
not you're good at delivering the ride.
Right?
Totally.
Yeah.
If,
as long as there's a reward,
that's the thing.
It's like,
I mean,
that's what you're doing right?
You're always playing off of something.
That's what a joke is.
It's like expectations of the
expectation and and there's
so many different ways,
a few different ways you can do that,
so I'm just going to be people that just
have different styles that they enjoy.
Like there's people that are gabriel
iglesias fans and people that tig notaro
fans.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
There's people that are fans of both.
Yeah,
totally.
I know I might go into those.
Those I'm like,
I like anybody.
That's funny.
Yeah.
I like,
yeah.
I like any music.
That's good.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a good way to say.
Yeah.
Results may vary.
The results may vary,
but like,
you know,
if you know,
it's just like,
it's a sincerity,
you know,
we all know is like comics.
If we're watching other comics up there
that we haven't seen before,
you can tell pretty quick when it's,
it's coming from an honest place.
Even if it's like they're a little
nervous,
you can tell they're nervous and they're
kind of playing a cool front.
Like you can tell that the jokes,
the point of view is coming from an
honest place.
Well,
it's also.
I think we lost that with djs.
There's chase.
Like when I was a kid I would remember
djs playing songs and it was sincere
appreciation for the songs they playing
because they did pick this song.
I really want you to dig the song and
you'd find a dj that you like.
You're really enjoyed his shell.
Oh,
he's going to be three to seven.
This guy's the shit.
He played great music and you listen to
him talk about the songs and there was
this authentic thing to it verses like a
jack fm station.
We're like,
here we go,
jack fmp,
all the hits,
all the difference all the time.
Twenty four slash seven fade right into
the music and like kiss your duh.
Yeah.
You get that with kids who are so donate
now to not just share hi Terry Cross.
All things considered.
I used to listen to that all the time.
Public radio,
international,
npr.
I used to listen to that all the time.
If a coleman,
that was my morning ritual.
Npr,
I act before they were podcast.
This is different than what other other
things you're hearing.
All things considered.
I love.
Wait,
wait.
They'll tell me.
Oh,
those are good.
It's a.
It's a pretty fun time.
It's pretty biting actually and it's
lightning fast.
I mean the wit on there.
It's just awesome.
Yeah.
Npr,
radio lab's nprs.
Radiolab.
Yep.
Yeah.
That was one of the best.
Podcasts are amazing that I've learned
more from radio lab that I did from all
my years of barely paying attention in
school.
Like for sure.
Yup.
Yeah.
I quote radio lab more than I quote at
most books I've read.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
I agree there.
They're absolutely fantastic.
I mean there's just like a lot of cool
shows on there that keith was wsdl
because they play so much dope music.
Like it's I discover like probably 80
percent of my music on really what
station is that a case vow?
It's a 93 point three zero or 89 point
nine.
I haven't listened to a radio station in
fucking years.
You should check it out on the radio in
years.
It's cool.
I just get the app and I stream it from
my app for my phone.
I listen to music when I
work out sometimes when I'm driving.
Yeah,
most of the time.
Listening to podcasts now,
89,
99 point nine,
city of licensed santa monica,
public broadcasting owner,
santa monica college.
How weird.
Yeah.
They're moving.
They got.
They got new location,
but they're like one of the most
influential radio stations in the
country.
I think that's the place where Henry
Rollins has a weekly show.
Totally.
Yeah,
a fanatic.
and fanatic.
good rounded.
Yeah.
He's great.
I mean you just get like this kind of
more like eighties radio feel.
Right?
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Like these underground guys are know
people like these really warm voices.
Like that was a new one from orbital
coming out with a single.
That's definitely definitely geared more
towards the kids from the 19 nineties.
If you remember that time period.
This is a new one for me.
You know,
like that kind of shit where you're
like,
oh yeah,
you feel like you're in a warm bath of
like,
oh,
what else?
What else you got?
The sudden your one from a flan turf and
then it's just like this weird angular,
gross sounding music and you're like,
how are you able to talk lIke that and
play that track?
And it was great.
I love the fact that people could just
play whatever they want.
Like we need more of that,
like totally tried for a long time to do
it the other way.
It doesn't work.
No algorithms for got spotify now and
you've got all that shit,
which I don't really dig but not as
much.
I mean I,
sometimes they'll do a radio station on
apple music,
uh,
but I like choosing.
I listened to albums so I listened to an
album for a long time and then I'll
switch to another album or I'll switch
to like three songs off of a record.
But I like choosing when I'm listening
to on occasion I have discovered cool
music by using the radio station.
But really for me,
I'd rather just do kcrw because then
there's a real human,
you know,
going,
hey,
check this out.
Yeah.
And it's.
And it's a rare treat.
Yeah.
I like that.
I like it.
I like keeping it a little bit more old
school when it comes to music discovery
and listening.
Well,
just the fact that you know that this is
rare now.
You know,
you appreciate it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Well,
we have to come back to it.
I mean the organic shit.
I mean that's why like anything I look
at technology,
it's like we're still kind of primitive.
It's not organic enough.
It's not an after thought.
we're not an afterthought mode.
It's not like,
you know,
technology should be like a light
switch.
I went to a restaurant the other day and
all of their furniture was made with
metal pipes and like would like this and
you know,
like that sort of crafty sort of feel to
things.
We're touching wood and brick on the
wall.
Like that's like suit and the menu was
written in a chalkboard.
Yeah,
totally want that shit now.
Oh,
they,
they liked the personal touch.
It makes them,
it reminds them of being human because
we're so digital most of the time.
Somebody gives you an ipad and the menus
and the ipad.
No,
I don't like it.
Don't like chalkboard over here.
Do not like to see the specialist on the
chalkboard.
Yep.
Not swipe to go.
Well,
what?
What kind of beer do you know?
Gross.
that's why I think monitors tv should
only be in sports bars and then keep
them out of all the
other places.
I'd love to just go.
I'm not a drinker,
but if I go to a bar with a with a
friend,
I love it when I go into a bar that's
just a bar.
It's just.
I mean,
and what I mean is there's no fucking
television.
It's off.
Maybe just in case for an emergency
broadcasts or something because there's.
There are peopLe gathered there
whatever,
but I like it when it's like there's no
fucking monitor.
People are just chilling and having
conversations with each other.
That's what a bar should be.
Should I be afraid?
Maybe you show blade on every screen
streaming 24 slash seven project it
projected on a screen just to soften the
light because otherwise you get that
screen glare,
which is a fucking asshole on super old
school.
Drive a fucking horse.
Yeah,
I do.
I do drive a horse.
that's,
that's the technical term for drive one.
Well,
we're going to long for the days were
engines were real.
one day we're going to be like,
remember when back when cars made noises
and you could hear him.
Come on.
Yeah,
totally.
It be like.
I remember when he used to drive him.
Yeah,
that was my favorite scene in I,
but he's like,
I'm going manual.
They're going like 300 miles per hour
and then the computer say or know the
person that the pastor said,
are you crazy?
Going to switching to manual at these
speeds.
I love that man.
It's like one day.
That'll be a thing of the past.
The spiritual wheels though.
I mean,
come on.
That was sick.
Yeah.
The car could rotate while it's still
maintaining the same speed forward.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
It was just coming to spheres.
Yeah,
they have them in factory.
Factory floor robots are like forklifts
now.
Oh yeah.
I forgot what they call that type of
steering.
Um,
but it's like crap.
It's basically crab,
like so it can move forward sideways.
Any,
any way.
How many years do you think we have
where it's still legal to drive your own
car?
I think we have prObably 10 years.
Ten years.
Sounds good.
That sounds about right.
yeah.
Yeah.
I feel like it's goiNg to creep in.
We are going to realize how much safer
it is.
People with some.
Some assholes are gonna fuck up with
manual.
They're going to crash into a school or
something like that and then people are
going to go enough with the manual.
Yeah,
enough,
you know?
Yeah.
But they'll do semI manual like you can,
you can,
you can steer,
you can drive within certain parameters,
but if the computer senses you're going
off the rails and we'll fucking guide
the car back.
Well,
you know,
that's why it's so.
There's such a demand for really old
cars that have tactile feedback.
Yeah.
They're so expensive.
Like if you buy a 19,
73 porsche,
which is only like 150 200 horsepower
engine.
If those things are in good shape.
Yeah.
Worth a fuck load of money now.
True.
Because you feel everything we drive in
that thing.
Yeah,
totally.
Every bumpy drive over you feel that
there's no power steering at all.
So you feel like turn on the steering
wheel.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're,
if you feel the force against the wheel
to and interpretation and when you turn
hard,
it's harder to turn way harder.
Yeah.
You got it.
You got to really.
You've got to be present with it.
Whereas like with new power steering,
you could kind of be absent minded and
be taking a pretty hard corner.
She's easy to roll the car.
Well,
difference in also the newest power
steering even opposed to the last
generations
now they do power steering.
That's electric.
Yeah.
It's fly by wire.
You don't feel a thing.
Whereas the hydraulic gave you varying
feedback depending on how much a load
was on our rack and pinion and I always
loved writing.
I thought that that was the perfect
happy medium.
Yeah.
Because it like,
well those really old cars were so light
like those old porsche's and old bmws,
like the bmw 2002 and by any bugs.
Yep.
So light.
You didn't have to have power steering,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
what people are doing now is they're,
they're,
uh,
they're pulling the transmissions and
engines and replacing them with
electric,
so you still have the road feel and the
handling of it,
but you get the battery,
you get the,
you get the battery so you don't get,
I mean it's not loud,
but you get this great fusion of like
you've got the classic car look,
but you've got the speed and the
pickups.
So kind of like this little tiny bmt to
bmw 2002 and you're doing zero,
63 point five seconds.
I saw somebody did that with a 1965
mustang.
They took a 65 mustang and turns it into
an electric car and it was like to be
sad.
It's a beast.
I know that when you're talking about
you're looking at this classic old
school muscle car and yet it has like a
tesla under.
Yeah.
It's like an electric muscle car.
I mean rimac.
Do you know the rimac or rhythmic there?
Estonian r I m a c and they make this a
electric car for electric motors motor
for each wheel.
Well,
it's got over a thousand horsepower.
jesus,
zero to 60 in three point two.
Something like that.
Three point is maybe even faster than
that.
M and a,
or.
No,
no,
no.
Two point two,
point three.
That thing's insane.
Listen,
because my card is two point three.
What car do you have?
A tesla p 100 d damn son.
Look at this thing.
This thing is beautiful.
It looks like one of those lexis copays,
those new lexus coops.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
See if they can have like a.
Yeah,
there you go.
That thing is beautiful.
yeah.
It's like,
it's crazy.
And so it does,
uh,
it,
it definitely does.
Um,
effectual steering and power.
This power distribution,
so it keeps things are gorgeous.
Can corner like a motherfucker.
And because the computer's monitoring
traction all the time,
if to each wheel with an electric motor
that has instantaneous torque,
you're able to steer the car with
acceleration.
So if you're coming around a corner,
depending on the mode and the way that
you're driving,
you can actually push the car around the
corner with the wheels using the input
from the steering wheel.
So your directional steering but also
visual steering at the same time.
So that car is disgusting.
It's just leaving this tesla behind you.
Just leaving it,
leaving it like it's parked.
Yeah.
This guy,
this guy actually does some good shit.
And so there's like some like young rich
guys that are always doing stuff,
but I like that guy.
He's going to race a.
All you
know is going to burry that ferrari.
The ferrari is history.
Is that la ferrari?
Yeah,
that's a it.
Yeah.
It's a ferrari laferrari,
which is hybrid.
That's crazy.
The remax remax going to win.
I know,
I think so.
Let's see.
Three,
two,
one go.
Oh my god.
Off the line.
Instantaneously.
Not even close.
It's just.
See you later.
It's linear power curve,
right?
It's an absolute.
It's a curve.
It's just a perfect curve of absolute
poWer.
That's insane.
Now,
where does one get one of these remax
you?
How far can they drive a yards?
Yeah,
totally.
It can go 200 feet per charge.
Find out how long those things drive for
it.
Let's take a guess.
I'd say they have 220 miles on them.
What do you say?
I'm going to say I'm going to say 180
miles.
Two hundred miles to 200 machines today.
You went low ball.
High ball on me.
Top top end of two.
Twenty five or something like that.
Which an electric car is a huge deal.
What's your tesla get?
What's the longest distance you drive?
Three 40.
That's pretty god damn good.
Something like that.
Or three.
You think about when tesla,
when they.
Oh,
like had a bunch of people.
What does it say?
Two point eight.
80 two kilowatt can get 200.
Five miles?
Yep.
Did they don't specify conceptual
driving to drive cycle?
Yeah.
So if you're driving like a maniac,
I'm going to say 1:50.
Yeah.
Maybe not even,
right?
Yeah.
One 40.
Let me think about.
Like during the hurricane in Florida,
tesla released a bunch of these cars
that had um,
they had restrictions on the,
uh,
amount of distance they could drive.
Oh yeah.
And so they did it remotely and they
gave these cars more of a distance.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They control speed.
Probably governed top to top speed.
No,
I think they actually literally have a
threshold of hoW far they,
they like you could pay more when you
buy them.
If you buy one,
you could have the option to have a 250
mile gas tank or a 350 miles a day.
We just unlocked the capability.
Exactly.
Interesting.
So the same but kilowatt battery
kilowatt battery.
Yeah.
I don't know about that.
I don't like that.
It's weird,
right?
I think.
I think as long as the battery system Is
modular so that you can add or take away
from it without like huge manufacturing
costs of changing the shape of the
battery,
which is that,
which is what tesla does.
You can either like elongate the body of
the car and then add more packs or you
can shorten the body of the car and
narrow it.
Less packs,
but I think it should just be packed.
Just fucking people over.
I just don't have the capability.
It's just a software thing.
I'm not going to cost any extra money
unless the idea this is,
but it's so weird.
It's like,
well then why not just make a
competitive lease for the battery
capacity that you want?
Or or they're like,
well,
why buy it for a small price now and if
you want to pay more later we can unlock
more battery potential.
The problem instead of like say if you
buy it engine and it has 800 horsepower
and then the,
you know there's another option.
You could buy the v six and that only
has 350 horsepower psych.
We're kidding.
The v six has 800 horsepower.
We're not going to let you use it
because you're not paying us.
That's what really what it is,
is because it's the same exact battery
pack that I don't like the,
that,
that I don't like,
that doesn't make sense.
Give intentionally.
They've crippled some of their cars and
the other ones they given you an option
to not crippled,
but we want you to pay more.
Well you need to have the same exact
hardware.
It's an,
it's an inept purchase.
Well it is kinda,
but it's uh,
it's,
it's way different because you're
talking about like a physical.
It's like almost if your phone,
do you have to pay more on your phone is
250 gigabytes versus 100?
Totally.
That's really what it is.
But yeah,
but it's like also the same as getting a
video game and you're like,
I've got the video game and they're
like,
would you like to unlock more content?
But see that's the journey you're on,
right?
Your video game is a portal to a
journey.
This physical device that has the
capability tO drive 350 miles,
like,
nah,
you can't have those 3:50.
I'll give you two,
200 miles.
How long,
how many times?
Like realistically,
I'm only driving like maybe 30 miles a
day,
but that doesn't matter,
but I'm just saying that if you want to
go across country,
the idea was like you could in the
future.
We'll see.
IT doesn't make sense.
I don't know if that's.
Is that a real thing?
It's a real thing.
Stupid just doesn't make any sense.
It's like you don't need to do that to
make money.
Well,
I guess if you just want to like unify
the manufacturing process so that you
can create a higher yield or something
like that.
You're looking at it like the man,
the man to me,
I'm looking at it as though the
congenial johnny blue collar consumer
fucking pissed.
I am pissed at you.
I,
you know,
I'm,
I'm just saying just saying I understand
red.
You want.
We're going to wrap this pitch up.
Yeah.
That's fair to say.
To wrap it out.
This is awesome man.
I know people talk a out.
They're like,
oh,
you should.
You should be on his show.
Pete,
you and I ran into each other the first
time we ever met a plane.
We were flying to london or something
together.
yeah,
that's randomly.
That is international plane.
We were like one seat ahead of each
other.
We took the face.
Yeah,
I put the selfie on instagram.
Remember that shit?
That's right.
That was a long time ago.
There wasn't a lot of time.
I think it was you.
Me and tony hinchclIffe.
Oh my god.
wow.
That was a while ago.
Long time ago I think.
I think we were on our way somewhere in
europe.
I want to say.
Yeah,
look at that.
That's us way from london to la from
randomly.
that's so crazy.
Crazy time travel,
man.
Yeah.
What year was that?
Young jamie?
Thousand.
January of 2015.
Just think at the moment we took that
picture.
We were simultaneously talking about
this moment reflecting on this picture.
Crazy man.
So in a way we were,
we were Times.
We were,
we were time traveling and we were on a
time travel shit.
Anyways,
stoked.
And now we're done.
Say goodbye.
Goodbye everyone.
Sleep well.
Goodbye.